Do Do,
do,
do a three,
two,
one.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Owen,
Benjamin,
how are you brother?
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for coming here man.
I appreciate it.
We're just talking about kind of being
outside of the bubble of the big cities
and living in a nice calm place.
You know,
you're calling now.
Yeah.
Like there's chickens.
That's the move,
man.
It's the move because you could visit,
you can visit this crazy fucked up
place.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's why when you,
uh,
when you asked me to do this,
I was like,
yeah,
I'm excited to visit La and then I'll go
back to like,
you know,
my brother and my family and a mountain
in a lake.
Yeah.
That's the way to do it.
If you could do it that way,
that's the way to do it.
Yeah.
See,
it's like there's some real benefits to
living in a city,
but there's also some real benefits to
being outside of it.
I think that figuring out some sort of
50 slash 50 thing,
like you're doing like visit and then
bolt,
that's the move.
Yeah.
It's also kind of altruistic,
like 3000 people.
I go back and forth between here and
there and I'm like,
if someone dies like everyone chips in,
if they can't afford it,
like that's it.
It works so well in small groups.
Yeah.
You know,
and then the bigger the group,
the more it gets a little dicey.
It's a totally different way of living.
I feel like living in a small group is,
you know,
as long as it's a good group,
you get stuck with a bad group and
that's a real issue to some crazy meth
heads that lived down the street and
they'd like to shoot things up in the
middle of the night.
Well that's part of your little small
group and I delivered papers to those
guys when I was a kid.
They just do the car thing or the bike
thing,
bike and walk.
Oh,
someone stole my bike.
So I went back to walking.
You haven't been developed some serious
fucking core muscles carrying around all
those newspapers.
Do you have a wagon or just do the bag
thing now?
I did the bag thing.
I used to carry my dog in it wrong dude,
for real.
If you think about that,
like people put sandbags on or a weight
vests on rather,
and they do all kinds of exercises and
it's like 40 pounds.
Well if you're like an adult,
40 pounds is like a good amount of
weight to do chin ups and pushups and
stuff with a weight vest on.
If you're a little kid.
How old were you?
Nine to 13.
Dude.
Think of how weak you are when you're
nine and someone's strapping down
newspapers on you.
Yeah.
That was Chubby to.
I bet it made you strong as fuck it.
It definitely helped me get into
puberty.
Yeah,
for sure.
And also like people do that for
exercise,
you know like farmer's walks.
You ever seen Pharma?
So yeah,
totally.
Hey,
put a bumper bar,
bar bell,
Kim's hill where he put a dumbbell in
each hand and just walk or Kettlebell
and just carry it.
Just walk,
just carry the weight of the world.
It also makes you emotionally strong to
like be nine and like have to knock on a
door like a pimp,
you know?
It's only a dollar.
That's right.
You got to collect.
Got Call as always a giant issue
collection.
Yeah.
I only had a couple people that had to
collect from,
by the time that I had started
delivering newspapers,
they figured out how to do like these,
uh,
withdrawals from people's accounts,
like,
you know,
they would do it,
pay for it in advance,
somehow know they're like,
get it like a bank account withdrawal or
something.
I didn't have to build them.
That wasn't my point.
But a couple people,
I didn't have these little envelopes.
You have to leave the Tan novel and they
put the money in the envelope.
It was so weird.
It was also outdated.
Yeah,
it was,
it was like 19th century newspaper
delivery and also like,
uh,
if someone said they left it and,
and you know,
that they didn't like someone else took
it and then they put it on a nine year
old.
It was like,
it was intense to have to argue them
down and be like,
no,
you do have to pay me.
I have overhead,
you know,
I've got my own girl and there's,
here's a little tip for people.
I don't,
I don't want to be that Dick,
but if someone asks,
if you put the the newspaper inside
their door,
you kind of have to do it.
You got to do it.
That's a real drag if you're driving,
because if you're driving when you want
to do is you want to just chuck that
sucker down the either the pathway or in
the driveway and keep moving.
Boom.
You got a lot of newspaper,
son,
keep moving,
keep moving.
If you've got a volume business,
a volume business,
you know,
and they'd be like,
you know what,
we'll take care of you on Christmas.
I'm like,
too,
there's no way it can be worth it.
It's like way more.
It's cold out.
I gotta get out of the car.
I've got to carry it.
I got to go all the way up your walkway
opening door.
That shit takes time.
She had to do that with every house.
It'd be impossible.
Impossible.
And also because the winters and we
didn't have plastic,
you know,
I was in a very outdated system.
You didn't have plastic for the bags
now.
Whoa,
that's crazy.
That doesn't even make sense now was it
was a badly run newspaper.
We had plastic sometimes,
but sometimes we just have rubber bands.
Like there was a,
like depending on the weather,
he didn't always have plastic,
but then they moved to plastic like
later.
New York Times always had plastic and it
was blue.
I took the New York Times route just
because there was extra prestige and
delivering the New York Times in my
mind.
That's hilarious.
Drug.
No,
I'm not usa today anymore.
Well,
I knew this guy who was really smart who
also delivered newspapers.
He was like a whole community of people
that deliver newspapers because this one
guy,
one guy I remember this dude is very,
very smart guy.
He was a music composer and he drove a
Hyundai and he was explaining to me how
much engineering and time that the,
the,
the South Korea had gone into before
they created this automobile.
He's like,
believe me,
he's like,
these will be so reliable,
like of Koreans are going to put out a
car,
it's going to be the shit,
like they are not going to fuck it up
and this dude delivered newspapers and
he had the New York Times as part of us
around.
I was like,
wow,
he's sophisticated.
He's into classical music.
He knows a lot about North Korea and
South Korea.
Efficiency.
Yeah.
I didn't know shit.
I was like,
well,
how has this guy knows so much?
I just knew like dinosaurs and sharks,
like I would just constantly read about
dinosaurs.
Like I could name every dinosaur,
but I didn't know anything about the New
York Times.
Did you see that new one that they
found?
The titanic source.
Now that sounds incredible.
Fuck yeah.
Does it took me back to being 12 again.
Also us.
What an awesome new pterosaur yeah.
That would like explain it to my friends
and almost take it like it made me big.
It's so big,
like eight cars could fit in it.
Oh,
it would be like,
whoa.
I think they said it's something like
eight elephants.
Something crazy like that.
Yeah,
it's gigantic.
It's the biggest dinosaur that they've
ever discovered and I feel like they
discovered it within the last decade
with the size of this motherfucker.
Jamie,
can you rewind that to the very
beginning where you see the full body
video really flow through.
The size is fucking thing.
Newly named speech is the largest mammal
animal.
Rather to ever walk the earth.
The titanosaur fossil was discovered in
Argentina in 2013.
Am I saying it right?
Titanosaur.
Scientists use try dimensional
reconstruction to measure the mass.
Ooh,
look at the size of that fucking thing.
God meet meter Veggie,
Veggie.
We're so lucky.
The thing could still be around.
It would win every fight.
This they did.
This is heavy as 12 elephants or a full
Boeing 7:37.
Jesus fucking.
Oh,
oh,
that's unreal.
The skeleton at the American Museum of
Natural History in New York is so large.
Dot Dot dot.
Well,
what is it that it's head sticks out?
Oh Shit.
That's embarrassing.
It's just too big of a dick.
Do you think duck ticks back then were
just like 20 feet long?
Ducts?
Probably had like,
yeah,
I mean duct Dick's today can be like
nine inches long for like a little tiny
duck.
Right?
Isn't that the deal?
Like Andrea's Antonopoulos?
Uh,
he,
he thought for some reason it was like
three feet long and he had me really
super psyched.
It's still pretty big.
It's not quite three feet long,
but what a crazy,
a little scenario.
The ducks have had to like duck dick per
body ounce must be like massive,
massive,
like a thigh.
Right?
Like if you had an,
a literally had another thigh
[inaudible] like the female duck has to
Vaginas,
party pussy.
Well they use the dig,
dig and decide to let you in at every
turn.
Yeah.
It's a labyrinth.
Yeah,
it's.
And that's why the duck dick is like
this weird curly q apparatus type thing
and the length because it's like the
little tiny factors will affect the next
generation.
So like one duck had like a slightly
longer windy or winter that could manage
the.
And there was this like really weird
discussion,
this really weird scientific discussion
about ducks and whether all ducks sex
was rape.
And I'm trying to think,
I was in on that one,
but they were trying to determine but
like coming from someone like me who has
chickens and I'd get to see these
animals behavior and other birds that
I've watched in my neighborhood.
I posted a picture on instagram
recently,
a hawk.
There's a
hawk war going on in my neighborhood and
wow hawks are killing hawks and they
kill them and they,
they cut their heads off and then they,
they eat parts of their body.
I'm pretty sure it's hawks doing it
because one of my neighbors saw a hawk
eating another hawk,
like a baby hawk in nest.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So they think that somehow another these
hawks,
he's young juvenile hawks are fighting
to try to take over this area.
It's like gang stuff,
dude.
It is gang stuff.
One of them came swooping into my
chicken coop the other day who has
slammed into the cage outside of the
chicken coop,
like the door was shut,
but it slammed into it like it was
trying to get in and get the chicken.
So I was like,
Whoa,
this dude is bolded.
Fuck,
I got an owl in my hood trying to get my
chickens to you are scary.
Bowels are terrifying.
They could take out a dog.
They're a big animal man.
People fucked up with our,
with those God damn movies,
making them the wise old cute thing
because it was still flying terror.
They're just out there to test and
lollipops and you know,
and giving out wisdom and lollipops and
given out wisdom.
Mad Dude.
When you see one in real life,
you're like,
oh,
you're a fucking dinosaur.
Oh my God.
Damn.
Flying talent covered dinosaur.
Yeah.
They took out a few of my chickens and I
got.
I got pretty pissed too.
I'm sure they did.
You know what man?
I am thinking in my neighborhood that
someone used some sort of a rodent
pesticide interest.
I really think that happened because I
was reading about this,
that some owls wind up dying because in
coyotes as well,
because they'll eat rodents that were
infected by this road and this road in
pesticide is poison.
They give for rats.
Just rat poison and animals eat the rats
and then they get it and die off and
they were talking about our goals and
specific were really important for
taking control of a population of
rodents.
Got Suite next to.
We still think of what they are mad.
They are flying murderers.
We just,
we,
we made them something cute.
Yeah.
Know like when you live in the woods,
it's your confirmed with that
constantly.
He's a raccoon sketch like raccoons can
in their intelligence level.
Like my brother had to kill them with a
pitchfork recently.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
It was.
Oh my.
I was trying to kill chickens.
Oh yeah.
And they'll,
they'll open like locks and stuff.
Like they have like fingers enhance did.
There was one in my neighborhood and he
was coming towards the chicken coop at
night and the chickens were going crazy.
It was late at night and I show him the
flashlight on him and he started walking
towards it.
Oh Man.
I was like,
fuck this.
Fuck this.
I'm out of here man.
And there's sound or scream is nuts.
Oh fuck that.
I want to hear a raccoon screen.
I saw guardians of the galaxy.
That little dude was the scariest guy.
Yeah,
a little raccoon with the guns and
smart.
He was smart as fuck.
You see two.
Haven't seen two yet,
Dude.
I cried on the plane watching it sweetie
now.
But like I don't really cry much in
life,
but every now and then
like some big archetypal movie,
we'll just grab me.
They can get you to.
Especially once you're a parent,
you know,
they're much more vulnerable.
What does that a duck dick.
We're looking at a duck duck right
there.
How is that even real?
They had here on the forced copulations
male ducks are notorious for attempting
force copulation with females,
so females seem to have involved vaginas
to make it hard for a male duck to
actually inseminate them if they don't
want to by forcing it towards the dead
ends.
Oh Wow.
They have dead ends.
They have like trap doors.
Of course,
male ducks haven't taken this lying
down.
The more forced copulation a duck
engages in,
the longer the male's penis is tend to
be according to a 2010 study.
Whoa.
So their dicks get longer.
The more they rape.
I wonder if the female duck like laughs
a letter like when the rapey ducks like
mad and she's like man,
because she like sent them the wrong
way.
Maybe she's going to be pregnant,
but I just keep spelling calories.
Look at this,
this quote.
In fact,
male ducks grow a new penis every year,
which means they can vary the length
depending on that year's competition.
Holy Shit.
You've mentioned if you.
Dick fell off every year like elk
antlers and every year it grew back like
for like months nobody had sex and
everybody was cool with each other and
we're like,
God,
can we just be like this all the time?
Like imagine if there was just like we
had a season half.
Maybe that's our problem.
We're such gluttons we should have a
breeding season.
We should have a season where literally
our Dick Falls off.
Such an egg grows back.
It grows back.
Look,
if you could reengineer people to have
like a three month period,
like a participants have off seasons
level off season where this no gender,
so there's no male,
there's no female,
there's no nothing.
Everybody.
Dick falls off and everybody just chills
out for a little bit and doesn't think
about anything but just life existential
shit,
you know,
get some rental property.
Think about like going to the beach more
like why don't I go to the beach more?
I always enjoy it.
Feels good when I'm there and then the
Dick size and shape will tell you what
the year is to come out.
It's a 15 inch or we got some serious
war ahead of us.
We've got problems.
Yeah.
Because like um,
chimp,
chimp ball size is directly
proportionate to the amount of slots
that are near them.
Whoa.
That's the thing with primates.
For some reason there was some
correlation between promiscuous females
and I'm like women having sex with more
than one in a derogatory term.
Just scientifically.
There were saying that women who are
having sex with more,
more males,
those males grew bigger dicks and bigger
balls.
Sperm competition.
Yeah,
like literally a balls got bigger.
I think that was like provable and want
to know if the Deq was provable.
People feel weird about studying dicks.
They do and there's so much.
There's so many great stories if you
study a day,
but if you're a dick dr people like,
hey,
why that fall into that box for years.
That's what I prefer to call them.
It's the correct nomenclature.
You know,
everyone wants to say penis,
but my daddy was a cock doctor.
His daddy was a cocktail doctor.
We've always been studying.
It seemed so important that everyone is
so ashamed of.
You read sperm wars.
You know what?
No,
I did not,
but I think that's been disproven.
There was a study that they did where
they could not recreate the idea that
some sperm actually attack sperm and
killed them.
They couldn't.
They couldn't show that there was a real
differentiation in cells.
Like there were cells that have the
ability to go out and kill other sperm.
They were saying that that was more
theoretical than anything in the guy who
originally wrote.
It might've like leap to a conclusion.
I can see that obviously,
I don't know shit,
but this is just what I had read was
that like scientifically it doesn't
really Jive,
but what does jive is with,
with primates,
this idea that the more females around,
the more you grow more balls and you
grow bigger loads.
I'm sure that definitely about load
size.
Do you think they measure load size
though?
How are they going to hold on chimp
before you come?
Come over here.
A little fella.
Bunch of pull out and.
And come on this trip over here.
Yeah.
How would you be able to tell?
How would you be able to study chimp?
Load size?
Probably just surrounded with a bunch of
squatty champs and then one brave dude
just has to check them off.
You know,
ones that brave champs will just rip
your face off.
Plus they know that a hand job is not
the best thing we can do better than
this.
Yeah.
Especially with a big old scientist man.
Hand start socking or you're not going
to get a sample.
Yeah.
And if it's a lady scientist,
you can't let a lady scientist go in
there jerk-off a chimp because that's
like some sort of prostitution almost,
right.
So it'd have to be a dude.
Either way.
The chimps gonna fuck you up if he wants
to beat the shit out of you while you're
jerking him off.
Yeah.
That would just be such a weird beating
black eyes jerking off a champion.
He freaked out.
He feels vulnerable at all.
Like you're going too hard.
Just like I get vulnerable with
handjobs.
Yeah.
Could you imagine if you like hurt
chimps,
Dick?
I mean,
it's not like you guys are communicating
in English or anything,
right?
You just jerking him off and you look
down and be like,
hey buddy,
it's going to be good.
I'm going to.
You're going to come so hard.
And then like maybe you fucked up.
You like maybe he likes it rough and you
kill them.
A couple of hard shakes and he just beat
you to a pulp.
Yeah.
Because you keep hitting these balls and
you don't realize it.
Just grabbing his dick in a way that
he's uncomfortable with anymore.
It's like I don't trust you anymore,
so before you movements were soft and
sensual and they seem like controlled
now you can't get on my dick.
It's like now you've got an agenda about
this hand job.
Yeah,
and I think to a chimp,
like any kind of violent display like
that,
that's like some sort of dominance
display.
When a chimp takes a stick and starts
banging it on another stick,
their balls get big and they just start
punching.
I don't know if that's how it happens to
balls get big with violence.
That's a good question.
That's a real good question.
I wonder if there's a correlation
between violence and um,
how much intercourse they have
because like I'm the Bonobos have the
most sex.
Would they have the least violence?
Right.
I wonder if that's just because that's
just who they are because they're weird.
They're,
they don't,
they don't.
Like,
they don't do a lot of the shit that
regular chimps do now.
And the females will just,
it's a,
it's a really funny nature channel.
And it's like,
yeah,
we have a male being angry and then it's
like.
And then like five checks of you,
like just start fucking him and now he's
asleep in the banana leaves role has
been averted for thousands of years.
Have they figured it out?
Just have a big old fuck party everyday.
Just drained balls and pussies as well.
We just keep everybody calm.
Everybody fucks everybody.
Everyone's fucking.
Yeah.
Because then you think it might be your
kid too.
So you have to like protect all the
kids.
They have rules.
The only rule is a mother will not have
sex with a son.
That's a solid rule.
This is the only one though,
guys.
Fuck their daughters.
It's weird.
The whole thing is,
um,
it's,
they have a strange system in that
regard.
Like this is the one taboo at this
incredibly promiscuous culture,
or I guess you'd call them a culture
species has.
They're fascinating man because there's
so much like regular champs,
but they're not violent at all.
Hardly.
They'd like make some noise and shit,
but they don't do much yet.
Almost perfectly splits our psyches as
humans to low.
We all have champion been oboe and us.
Well.
Just knowing that that's possible too.
Yeah.
Like that.
What what we are is just sort of like,
you know,
even like what we are as a culture,
it's just sorta Kinda like worked into
this spot and that's what it is.
You know,
what,
what we are.
It didn't have to work out this way.
You know,
it could have worked out some other
really weird way,
like all life forms that you see around
me.
We can be dolphins,
they think dolphins are as smart as us.
They think it's entirely possible that
without the context of our culture,
like our ability to display intelligence
through tests and math and can building
things engineering to without any
ability to display that.
We don't really know how smart they
actually are.
We just assume that the social
intelligence they have is not as
valuable as that.
The intelligence is evolving and
creating things,
but they have a cerebral cortex is 40
percent larger than a person's pets.
Intense.
It's intense.
There's all our.
All our tests are based on what we
value.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Well,
what we appreciate.
I mean,
I'm sure there's some other tests that
they do and they know that some really
complex language that they have that
they don't,
they can't decipher,
they still haven't figured out what the
fuck they're saying.
They know that there's dialects,
they know there's dialects and they know
that dolphins can understand a lot of
the things that we tell them.
But uh,
they,
they don't exactly know what the fuck
they're saying.
That's for sure.
They've never broken it down,
like to remembering the close
encounters.
Do they broke it down?
You're like,
oh,
there's a whole language here will see,
you know,
and they tried to figure out what the
language was there.
They've been studying dolphin language
forever and they're like,
who knows what the fuck?
They're saying two dolphins
blowing my mind.
Dude,
there are.
But they also do some fucked up shit
too.
They do a lot of infanticide.
Sex Slaves.
Yeah.
They kill babies.
It's a real common thing like it is in
all of nature.
Unfortunately,
males killed the babies.
Have A,
you know,
if it's not his kids,
find a woman who killed her babies.
It's really crazy that that's,
that's the code of somehow or another
and that was the way to do it,
like Ooh,
like somehow or another of all the years
of these things trying to improve to get
to the position they're at now,
to be the most sturdy,
the most viable,
the most complex,
the most,
the most able to figure out a way to
survive have to all that.
One of the options for one of the
smartest things on the planet is eat
babies get eat the babies of other
dudes.
Yeah.
It's like a race to the bottom and
morality for efficiency on Allen because
it's like it's.
You can see how quickly that works.
You know your genes go,
there's don't,
but it's like so disturbing.
Here's the thing.
Do you think that there's a massive.
I mean there's got to be a massive,
massive advantage in being able to
physically record things that people
have learned and to be able to recreate
them in the way that only we can.
Like as much as we can say that dolphins
are intelligent and I'm sure they are
and they might,
their brains might work better than
ours.
Who the fuck knows,
but our brains,
we have this weird ability to manipulate
things on dry land and that means we
figured out electricity and that means
we figured out electronics that we've
figured out.
Electronic storage and shit like this,
the Internet,
twitter,
instagram,
instantaneous access to information
about stuff.
Like that's just changing everything.
Yeah.
Because most like a life form.
It's unreal because we can act out
things in the abstract and not actually
have to do them and then create
something bigger.
Yeah.
But I'm not sure we're smarter.
I think collectively we are,
but like as individuals,
like dolphin literally might be like a
more potent mind than ours.
Yeah.
Well pigeons or have incredible
abilities that we don't have really?
Yeah.
They can go like five,
6,000
miles to the same spot without a map or
rightly those homing pigeons.
Yeah.
The,
what are they using?
Like magnetic fields,
what are they using now?
I mean that to me is so intense.
You know,
Nicola Tesla was in love with a pigeon.
Oh yeah,
I heard that on this show,
actually talking about that.
That's hilarious.
That guy was deep.
Yeah.
He could make money on any of his own
shit that all he could do is just love
that pigeon.
Well,
he was just so super duper off the
charts smart.
Yeah.
That,
I think he had a tremendous difficulty
in interacting with regular people,
you know,
and this guy just wasn't the best
businessman in the world.
He was just a super genius inventor.
That's what he was crazy though.
Massively,
massively.
Um,
W,
what would it be?
The word eccentric?
Yeah.
I think there's a level of intelligence
where you start almost becoming
destructive.
You know,
it's like that funny bought on south
South Park.
Remember I was like,
the greatest joke in the world is to
kill everyone and say awkward where like
if you do the math of stakes of jokes
and then like the,
like all the math of it,
it could get real dark.
And that's kind of like,
some people are so smart.
They're like,
why wouldn't I love a pigeon?
It can go 5,000
miles,
you know,
and you're like,
they don't have that thing that tells
them just weird.
Yeah.
Well he didn't care anymore.
I think he loved the pigeon more than he
loved people and it might not have been
like a romantic love.
Might've been like some spiritual thing
he ever seen that there's one photo of
him that's so iconic.
It's Nikola Tesla sitting in front of a
pair of Tesla coils and he's got his
legs crossed and he looks like the
master of the universe.
He literally looks like a character in a
marvel comic book.
That guy was a wizard,
like a lid.
Literal Wizard,
you know?
I mean,
how,
what?
Look at this guy look at this
motherfucker.
He's sitting there reading shit.
He's,
he's sitting there with his legs crossed
in this crazy electrical thing is going
on behind them and that's the guy that
would fall in love with pigeon.
That was like in his mind,
he's like,
yeah,
I'll just make all these crazy sparks
with my brain and read a book and then
just.
Well,
the pigeon.
Can you imagine what it must be like to
be a guy as smart as that like clearly
like a next level intellect.
Like there's like us,
there's normal folks and then there's
these like super genius like you know,
like a Lebron James of thinking,
Jesus Christ,
what the fuck?
How's he doing that?
And that's what that guy was imagined.
Being that guy and just seeing all these
things that haven't been figured out
yet.
How come you guys have done this?
That must be so frustrating about doing
this.
How about you have electricity just sit
in the air.
You wanted to fucking pump electricity
in the air where you would get it for
free.
Like the radio.
That must be like being around drunk
people all the time,
like being that smart around normal
people.
It's like being sober at a bar and I've
ever been to like on my penis and you're
like,
what's wrong with you?
And that's probably Tesla with like us.
It's like,
oh,
you can't just make the sparks.
It's a very good way of describing it.
That's probably exactly what's going on.
I've talked to a bunch of like really,
really smart people and at the time
doing this podcast and then off
podcasts.
One of my favorite examples is John
Carmack.
Do you know who he is?
He's like this super genius coder who
wrote the Three d engine for id
software.
I guess he'd be like,
be like the lead programmer or something
for it software.
One of the founders like quake and doom
and all those three d games.
Like he invented those things sunrail
and
every time I talked to him I'm like,
I'm barely your species.
Fairly.
Same species.
His brain is firing so hard and so fast.
You're like,
wow,
I'm such an ape.
Or you can see that on twitter with Sam
Harris sometimes and sometimes he'll do
a comeback and I'm like,
I got to read like nine books.
Even get that Sam stupid smart.
It's like crazy smart.
He's very smart,
very smart.
There's a lot of people like thought
man,
and they'll uh,
they'll give you a real reality check if
you think you're smart.
You think you're an exceptional mind.
My wife has her masters in structural
engineering and a lot of my buddies are
super conspiracy shit.
Nine slash 11 truther no,
that's what happened.
That's what happened.
One of my biases do.
They proved that a building can't fall
that way and my wife just called me just
goes,
but I'm they.
Oh Shit.
She's like,
I know how the structure of buildings
work and she wasn't saying it
maliciously.
She was like trying to be like,
no,
but I'm write silly.
There's still,
you know,
it could still be a thing.
I'm not saying it isn't true.
I'm just saying that like she was saying
it is possible for a building to fall
directly on top of itself is all she was
saying.
Well you know,
that whole tower seven thing so
fascinating because that's the one thing
where everybody points to when it comes
to nine slash 11.
Now what a lot of people don't know is
that there's a longer video.
When you watch the thing collapse,
it absolutely looks like a controlled
demolition.
And the problem with that is if you're
not an actual engineer and you don't
really know how they built that
building,
it was unusual if you don't really know
enough about it.
Like there's a lot of things that I kind
of know about,
but I don't really like if I,
if someone had,
if I had to explain a double clutch
transmission and like a,
a bmw,
I think I could half asset.
But if there was someone right next to
me that knew,
that really knew about it,
they would go with the fuck.
Are you talking about,
you know?
Yeah.
Like the half truth confidence can be
hilarious.
Oh yeah.
We gotta be real careful with that shit.
It's like,
listen,
I've read buzzfeed know you have this
like this knowledge balls without.
Because that's what's a getting a little
infuriating with me now is a lot of the
things being debated.
I actually know a ton about.
And like,
like I was a world war two history
major.
Like who lived in the Czech Republic,
studying authoritarian governments and
stuff.
And like so like,
I mean I'm not like an expert expert.
Like you sometimes you have people on
the show actually read books about tons
we're about.
So when they get the most basic things
about the,
everyone's a Nazi,
this is and then you because then you
can't point out the actual Nazis and you
know,
and just how it and everyone thinks that
it's left wing right wing,
but it's really not like,
like right wing dystopia would be like
Mad Max.
Like there's no government at all and
left his communist or socialist fascism.
It's just like the government is
everything.
Yeah.
You what man?
I'm,
I felt the need for everything to be
conspiracy is a real problem.
It's a real problem for a lot of people
that need to know that they're right
about things is a real problem.
You know,
the,
the not admitting that you don't really
know part is a problem because until
you.
Until I'm absolutely certain that what
you're saying like I have to know when
I'm talking to you,
if you say I'm absolutely 100 percent
positive,
that if I liked this paper on fire,
it'll burn 100 percent.
If this is regular paper and I have a
regular fire,
I'm 100 percent positive.
I have to.
If I have to hear you say if I have to
know that that's how you really are
operating.
So if you're telling me it's 100
percent,
the Kennedys driver shot him.
Dude,
it's 100 percent.
You watched the video.
It's 100 percent.
Kennedy's drivers shot him or any,
any kind of crazy conspiracy like that.
As soon as you say you know for sure
it's like God damn man to a,
you know,
for sure that it wasn't a plane hit the
Pentagon,
you know,
for sure.
How do you know for sure?
Right.
I agree with you completely.
You can't know for sure and if everyone
agrees,
like I always get freaked out when like
everybody agrees on everything.
I feel like I'm in a cult.
Yeah.
It gets,
it gets super culting bolt on both sides
as being a skeptical person.
Like there's a lot of people that are
skeptics that they'll look at things
even like operation northwoods and
there'll be like,
well,
that just.
It didn't.
No big deal.
If they were planning on killing
Americans,
they were going to rm Cuban friendlies
and have them attack one bay.
They were trying to get us to go to war
with Cuba and they were going to
manipulate us.
They were going to blow up a drone
jetliner and blaming on Cuba,
so we'd be outraged.
We want to go over and kick Cuba's ass
would cost.
Who knows?
Countless thousands of American lives
for sure because you know you're talking
about 1961 or two or whatever it was
when they.
When Kennedy vetoed this shit signed by
the Joint Chiefs of staff,
they were really going to do this.
Like anybody who doesn't look at that
and get disturbed.
This is from the freedom of Information
Act.
That's not a conspiracy.
The problem with the really wacky
conspiracies like Kennedy's drivers shot
him or you know the,
the,
the goes deep as you want.
Yeah.
The really wacky ones distract from the
real ones.
They mask it.
It makes it so nothing means anything
else.
Alex Jones was st something fucking
crazy today.
Like there was Jewish actors pretending
to be Nazis in Charlottesville.
Like these guys had tattoos of swastikas
on their chest.
It's not a fucking.
He's not Jewish person because you're
not supposed to get tattooed.
Right.
It's not a fucking actor.
Once you tattoo a swastika on your chest
that you're not acting anymore,
right.
You've committed to a team.
Jesus.
That's like one of the biggest steps I
can possibly think of as a human being
is to go to a tattoo parlor and be like,
give me the fucking craziest one.
I saw this a gay flag Nazi thing to try
to take the swastika back.
That's like a bid that I had
in 2014 about Cammo.
I was talking about those duck dynasty
guys are.
They kept talking shit about gay people.
I'm like,
dude,
they're going to take over cammo.
They'll fuck with you.
And they'll just,
they'll just.
Every gay porno from now on takes place
in Cammo.
It's like trucker hats,
like a lead from like truckers being
like,
we're fucking great.
And then a minute later they're like,
I'm not Justin Bieber.
I just like Miller lite.
Yeah.
The idea was that every porno film ever
made would be made in a duck blind.
The average Jane Porno,
bro,
that's fucking genius,
and every.
They would all start out with this way,
man.
Gai is black guy.
You could ever find going some about
duck hunting.
Make me hold.
That's fucking genius.
White dude comes in on chains and drops
to his knees.
Start sucking.
That's they're all in Cammo because
that.
Because then they can't just do it
without like having to apologize to
people and be like,
dude,
we're not into all that shit.
My point was like,
it started like they took over the
rainbow.
They could take over that too.
They can take over Cammo.
They can take over everything.
Connected visual light.
Yeah.
Light sticks,
yellow,
green,
blue,
indigo.
It's like,
you know,
most,
most people just have.
It's like,
oh,
we're the environmental.
It's like,
oh,
you get green.
It's like we're saying we want all the
fucking cars to get it like a southern
accent immediately.
What do you think the gay brainbow thing
has done to the Leprechaun industry?
Probably tripled it.
Crippled it,
that they think they got gold,
they find a gay bar in the middle of
Ireland.
Thousands of it was.
It was about finding a pot of gold of
the rainbow.
Now it's about what happened,
what the fuck did they do because they
culturally appropriate and it from the
leprechaun culturally,
appropriately or from the leprechauns
and fucking owned it.
Owned it.
Like shoot.
Tip owns cotton swabs.
Owned,
owned it in a period of like what?
10,
20 years.
All colors.
They own the rainbow,
the whole Rainbow Reiki.
If you think about when,
when the fuck was the rainbow first
discovered long time ago,
long time ago,
when was the first Leprechaun story,
the pot of gold.
That's probably hundreds of years of
leprechauns being associated with
rainbows.
Right?
And now it's just dude and dudes.
Just one day it just became,
it just turned and that's a hard turn to
from like,
oh,
it's sunny and rainy at the same time.
Oh,
now it's gay and it's just also taking
all the colors.
I just felt like,
you know,
gun control was the orange color and
it's just like they get all of them.
You know what's interesting,
it's when you think about like men and
women,
like in a straight culture like straight
men and straight women.
I wonder if there's more violence with
straight men and straight women than
there are with gay men like gay
community.
So I wonder if it's like poor capita of
the gay communities have less violence.
That'll be really fascinating to me.
There was more males together and less
violence versus males and females
together.
I feel like there's two effects
happening simultaneously.
Like it,
it could make it go down or up because
it's like you're always drained balls
because gay dudes,
gay dudes are constantly going around
and say no,
the blow job,
car ride had know and then.
But then the flip side is you're
doubling the amount of testosterone and
crazy and like if you get into a fight
with your partner and there's nothing
saying like,
but you can't hit women,
you know,
beat the fuck out of each other.
It's real bad.
Totally.
Dudes in a backyard brawl after they
butt fucked and then start fucking
during the fight.
They just get hot.
Yeah.
Oh you bitch.
And luckily he gave me a plaque.
I pitch do.
I bet lesbians don't fight much.
Hm.
That's a good.
That seems like a sexist thing to say.
Owen.
Benjamin.
Yeah.
I can't wait to call you out.
I love it.
I love you and go that route because
that it's so quick.
It's so sexist and then you've made a
good point and you're clearly not
hateful and then they're just like.
So like,
what do we do now?
It's like the kid stay mad when you're
like,
no,
you double men and then you're going to
get dudes who love working out and like,
you know,
real estate.
I wonder if that's the case though.
I wonder because I just guessed about
the statistics.
What do you think they would be?
Let's look them up,
but before we do that,
what do you think it would be?
Do you think there'd be less violence in
the gay community?
I think there would.
That's my guess as far as domestic
violence partner violence in general.
Violence committed to it.
I'm going to say less violence.
I'm gonna say less violence,
less violence.
Jamie,
what if we got.
I'm trying to find it.
All I've found so far,
most of it was about hate crimes,
so digging.
That's the problem because they get
victimized by people outside of their
community.
I found one that says is there's a study
that suggests that same sex
relationships suffer higher levels of
domestic violence and heterosexual.
Interesting.
That's just like a study.
So was it by like Christian workshops on
the BBC reporting it,
but I couldn't.
Oh,
and I'll just violence more common in
same sex relationships.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what does,
I don't know.
It doesn't say how much violence.
Yeah.
I feel like they have more in common.
Like less arguing.
Right?
It's like maybe not though.
Domestic violence is a weird word,
right?
It's like it's extra creepy violence
because violence against someone.
You care about your,
your near them and you lose your temper
to the point where you're enacting
violence on someone,
at least at one point your life.
You probably loved right now.
Right now.
You want to get violent with them,
like physically violent.
So dangerous.
I'm actually being a cop walking into
that shit.
I can't imagine.
Especially when you can arrest the guy
and like,
you're like,
this chick's gonna die eventually got
some heavy,
heavy shit.
Fuck
cuts.
Another reason why I think it's so like,
it's such worse violence because you
always.
In my head I'm like,
it's a dude beating a woman,
you know?
Yeah.
Even though the other way does happen,
but you just don't really.
I don't know.
I don't know,
man.
It's all fucked up.
It's like just the,
the fact that people can fall apart so
bad.
They get to the point where at one point
in time they love this person.
This person was probably like super
important to them.
Yeah.
And now you want to kill them.
You want to stab them.
You want to beat them up.
You want to hit them in the head with
something like,
woof,
you're off the tracks.
Yeah,
because kind comes from the word can,
like you're supposed to love your can.
You know that word comes from kind.
Yeah.
Ken?
Hmm.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
You treat kinfolk.
Kinfolk.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Did kind bud come from kind of bud?
Yeah.
That was always like the weird hippie
thing.
Like that was one of the sure fire ways
where you didn't want to get high with
somebody if they offered you some kind
bud.
Hey Man.
Fucking listen bro.
We're going to have a conversation about
astrology that I really can have right
now.
It is a red flag to it and astrology
Combo.
I'm fucking tired and I don't want your
nonsense.
I don't want to hear about your
channeler.
spiritual advisor.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
kind is nonsense.
Talk.
Do a door opener kind bud kind of bud.
That's so funny.
It's kind bud.
Man.
We had good weed and not good.
We'd like is okay.
It's pretty good.
It's mid grade.
Mid Grade.
If you were lucky you would say these
are meds,
meds,
and we just had weird.
Yeah,
and you just like from like 1997 on.
It's just been space we'd.
It's not even the same,
it's not even the same thing.
Everybody denies that.
It's crazy.
From the moment I started smoking weed,
it's been space.
We'd like to start def death experience.
I have with Joey Diaz.
Was it about that that that felt like
mushrooms,
like it felt closer to mushrooms and it
did weed in my mind.
I explained it in the poly short
podcast.
I explained too much,
but I'll explain it one more time.
When he eat marijuana,
it's processed by your liver and it
produces something called 11 hydroxy
metabolite and it's way more like four
to five times more psychoactive than thc
and it does.
It's a totally different feel like it
feels like a cycle,
like a psychedelic drug.
Yeah,
like a really potent one to like.
Especially if you go super deep.
It gets really weird,
especially when you lie down with your
eyes closed.
If you get like that and you're really
freaking out,
one thing that can kind of bring you out
of it that you can see if you can enjoy
this,
go somewhere dark and close your eyes
and like if you're really freaking out
on weed,
I bet there is a light show for you to
watch.
Like it'll be like for me,
one of the things that I remember like
consistently I would see neon cartoons
having sex like neon old school,
goofy old school,
Mickey mouse cartoons with.
They're moving weird but there were made
out of neon and they were having sex
with each other and creating more and
they were like,
like a like branching off like a,
some sort of a fractal.
It was fucking crazy.
Neon sex fractal has to be the name of
your next.
It was psyched.
I was seeing it all in front of me and
three d too,
like I was on some Disney ride.
It was happening all around me was.
I was like,
this is crazy.
This is just a weed.
And it's crazy when you make the jump
where you realize someone's showing you
something versus you imagining something
where you're like,
oh,
I'm just watching something else versus
like picture a helicopter.
There it is.
But it's just like,
Holy Shit,
this is something I've never seen before
and I don't know who's showing it to me.
Yeah,
there's something going on and to deny
it is really interesting because it's.
I think it's another one of those things
much like.
But people want to talk about.
I know for a fact something was a
conspiracy.
They also want to say I know for a fact
that this is a hallucination and that's
all it is.
I know for a fact that this is just
chemicals interacting with your mind,
but your whole life is chemicals.
You mean?
Your mind is like constantly processing
different chemicals,
whether it's adrenaline or whatever it
is with different emotions.
There's a lot of different things going
on chemically in your body all the time.
And then there's the big one which is
when your eyes shut and you go to sleep
and then you imagine a bunch of shit
happening.
It's not really happening.
Yeah,
like whole civilizations have been built
on like the reverence for what you're
talking about,
so it's not like there's definitely
something going on there easily.
Could be something going on.
There could be different frequencies
than our normal biology is tuned into a
very specific frequency and when
something's off,
it could be that they're not picking it
up.
Like maybe that's one of the things
about schizophrenia,
right?
They have these issues with their brain
chemistry.
Maybe they're tuning into a totally
different world at us.
Maybe their world is like the fucking
dark city.
Remember that movie with Kiefer
Sutherland upside down?
Yeah.
Everything is fucking hell.
Everybody's got like four foot long
fingers and they fucking creeping around
corners.
Maybe in their world everything's
completely fucked because they're tuned
in with their,
their own brain chemistry.
Literally they're interacting with the
universe around them.
It's such a different way that like
their world is dark and scary and ugly
and twisted.
It's like a filter.
Like when I learned about dark matter,
like I said,
I lost all Hubris that I know anything
like that.
Seventy percent of the universe.
It is this thing that we can't see or
feel or measure anywhere and we have no
idea what it is.
I was like,
y'all don't fucking know about tower
seven men.
That too.
Good way to describe it.
There was something really recently
about dark matter where they were saying
that they think that dark matter is
stored inside black holes.
Saving even find that so what the fuck
is a black hole to even get that?
That one's.
That one's a mind bender.
Like what?
What's happening out there?
There's some infinitely
dense point and everything is getting
sucked into it and it's eating it,
but it's eating planets.
Yeah.
What the fuck did you just say?
And it's instant,
but to the thing.
It's aternity.
Yeah.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
So there's something out there that's
eating planets.
Does dark matter,
is dark matter less lumpy than
predicted?
Oh,
that sounds racial.
It could be racial or at least gender
specific.
That's not gender specific.
If dark matter was a person,
what Pronoun would it use?
A man that's an intense one.
Zero.
Sorry,
say it,
but you can say zero to.
You can say whatever you want.
It's just made up.
I mean there's going to be a rule around
how to say it,
but see that.
Yeah.
It's like when it comes to gender stuff.
See that's when I stopped.
That's when I have a little bit of an
opinion where I'm like,
there are men and there are women.
Yeah.
But there's also a spectrum,
right?
I mean there's women that want to fight
in MMA and they want to race cars and
then there's men who want to be
florists.
Yeah.
But I feel like that's gender role
spectrum.
Like my dad is like a really flamboyant
opera singing,
like he's real fruity and my mom is like
six foot loves sports,
sweatpants,
crushes.
And it's like.
But my mom is such a great woman and my
dad's such a great dad.
And that's why sometimes,
you know,
at my piano teacher got a sex change
when I was 11.
So I,
I've been thinking about this stuff for
quite some time where I got to see the
same person on different hormones as my,
you know,
and I'm a classical piano player.
This is one of the most important people
in my life I'm still friends with and
it's like to see like it,
you know,
transition.
You're like,
oh dudes are way different.
Just the way the behavior change.
Oh yeah,
totally.
When it comes to like,
you know,
I'm just like,
what you're focusing on your level of
patience when he transitioned to a.
she,
yeah,
and I know on Halloween and I was like
trying to work on a,
on Halloween while I was trying to work
out a bit about that.
It's like the best time to like make
that hard turn because people think it's
a costume and then by Thanksgiving
everyone's like,
oh this is real.
Oh No.
Yeah.
Like if someone like Steve O did it
right,
you'd be like,
look,
this is,
I know what you're doing.
You're not getting me with this.
This is a scam.
It would take forever.
He would not be accepted.
It would take like months before people
knew it wasn't just a gag.
They're like,
yeah,
it's a five year gag,
like Tom Green.
That seems like something Tom Green
could almost get away with people like,
no,
God dammit.
We're seeing the Tom Green show 20
times.
Yeah.
It's like a bucket with the boys with
the impractical jokers and I'm always
wondering like if,
if one of them like really needs help
and public like,
is everyone going to be like,
it's sal.
It's a good point,
you know,
because people will assume you're doing
a joke and you're like,
no,
but I'm not joking.
That's a real good point because if you
choke on often.
Oh Shit,
dude.
That's a fucking good point.
Wow.
It's like a movie man.
Well,
it's a plot for a movie dude.
No way,
Bro.
So right now I was like,
this could be like a,
a big film man.
I'm feeling it,
but I think it's going to change the
world.
Practical joker goes out and has a life
threatening illness and then doesn't get
rescued because that realizes that
practical jokes are wrong.
That's the moral Mazarra yeah.
What else is there?
I'm Ashton Kutcher.
You've got to have the cool black
friend.
Of course,
practical joker has the cool black
friend.
She keeps it real,
but it's relatable.
She should have a gay neighbor or no,
I think everyone has to be gay.
Something has to happen right now.
They all have a gay dick once,
like every year,
like memory.
We're talking about.
You get the new Dick,
you get a new one every now and that
every eight.
Dick's is gay.
Who see you see?
You know about the community.
Oh,
like every eight.
Once you count them off,
like a very specific number.
Yeah.
Magic people like did do that.
And then you came back gay this year.
Damn.
This year came back gay bro.
It's my first time.
He was trade all 30 years.
You have all 30 years.
That's crazy.
That's a good run.
It's a good run.
So I'm looking forward to getting
ripped.
I'm just hoping it's a seasonal thing.
You know,
my uncle was gay for a year.
He had three gay Dixon road.
He lost his wife,
Bro.
It's not phone man.
My first grade duke.
Where would that be?
That we would have a whole different
attitude?
God Damn all these,
uh,
all these bigots that have problem with
gay people know that that wouldn't
exist.
That's like get.
Dale has to go away for a year.
He's got rollerskate time.
He'll come back and be hateful again.
You know,
there'll be kids in school,
Bro.
Let me tell you something.
No one in my family's ever got a gay
dude.
I'm not getting the gate deck,
Bro.
It's like the guy who was like losing a
little bit of heroin.
He's in high school.
Listen to me Bro.
My fucking hair is fine.
Yeah.
No one in my family's ever lost her
hair.
Overcompensate guy.
There's no gate dicks in my blood line.
Dude.
It's all straight guys.
Listen,
no one in my family is a serial killer.
Okay.
Then you start revealing shit about
yourself.
Like whatever you're insecure about you
like secretly are woo.
Woo.
Damn is deep.
Well sometimes I feel like I'll find
myself hating on a group of people and
I'm like,
something about me is that or else I
wouldn't,
you know,
like hipsters.
I remember I always,
I always hated him.
I called him indoor cats and uh,
and then I realized that hating hipster
itself is a hipster move.
Oh,
totally.
I'm like,
no,
dude.
I was like that before hipsters.
And I'm like,
holy fuck.
A hipster would say that I could have
easily been a hipster if they caught me.
I like,
I could've been assigned technology if I
didn't know better.
You know what I mean?
I just would have walked into the wrong
door,
took one of them personality tests and
go,
man,
maybe get my shit together with these
people.
Yeah.
Maybe I could be on one of these crazy
wacky levels.
It's the same thing.
I couldn't be a hipster.
I've got to have a weird mustache.
Twisty mustache.
Yeah.
It's like what Jordan peers and talks
about the shadow self.
I can be like really into micro beers.
Yeah.
I could live out my life in 18,
20 in Austin,
Texas.
I can wear really tight jeans and tell
everyone I'm a photographer because I
have an instagram account.
$300.
Yeah.
And they all have those,
those shoes.
Do you know those uncomfortable looking
like Italian looking shoes?
Yeah,
Dave Lewis makes.
It's like,
hey,
they go to like a cobbler,
hipster cobbler,
but there's something kind of cool about
it too.
I know.
Like those shoes right there.
Those are totally hipster shoes.
Jamie.
You nailed it.
You goddamn nailed it.
That's the perfect shoe for hipster.
Yeah,
low.
Think low cut one would be like a little
bit more hipstery.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Oh,
that's a hipster shoe.
If I've ever seen one.
Good Lord.
I'm too hard.
Turns in my life away from wearing those
shoes right now.
That's really called a hipster to John
Varvatos.
Star USA.
Hipster Chucka.
Boom,
Chucka.
Boom.
I didn't even know that.
That was a thing until now.
Chukka boots.
What's a chuck of boot?
Isn't it weird when you see two k's next
to each other?
Like makes you think it's racist?
Totally.
It is.
Now you can't do that anymore.
This should change this immediately.
I'm triggered.
I'm so triggered.
Everybody should be
the got real problems in this country.
It's not a joke anymore.
Yeah.
That charlottesville thing that just
showed everybody when you saw those guys
walking down the street with those
Citronella,
home depot torches,
I was like,
this is the craziest fucking thing I've
ever seen in my life.
Screaming white lives matter.
Crazy.
Like,
you know who said it best?
Man,
I have a great quote.
Sturgill Simpson sent me this.
Um,
because uh,
he had an email exchange with Dr Rick
Strassman,
who's the guy that wrote a dmt the
spirit molecule and uh,
they had an email exchange.
He said,
for starters,
I would say this is Rick strassman
saying this,
that what we're seeing is a failure of
the educational system.
This is due to faults within the system
itself as well as attacks on the system.
That system from outside,
by forces and institutions that gained
to benefit from ignorance and addiction.
Both religious faith and the love of
community have degenerated into crude
parodies of what they're capable of
being regarding where this is all
heading.
He says,
my zen teacher used to say that the
force of good,
this is what we thought was really
interesting.
The forces of good relative to the
forces of evil,
evil are always around 50 point one
percent versus 49 point nine percent.
There's a similar notion in Judaism
along these lines that the future of the
world depends upon single individual's
actions and I think it says something
like paradoxical,
like we are a speck of dust and the fate
of the universe hinges on us.
Wow.
That that quote right there,
we are a speck of dust and in in quotes,
the fate of the universe hinges on us.
That when I read that today,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Like that's so true.
Yeah,
and when you see this right now,
like what's going on with
Charlottesville and what's going on with
the way trump is reacting to it all and
the way people reacted to it all and
people are digging in their heels and
form and signs and this is any group,
any group that wouldn't think that this
is completely insane and totally out of
control in any group of people that
wouldn't think that someone driving a
car into a group of protest or just
randomly running over a girl.
Any group that wouldn't denounce that
instantaneously as one of those heinous
things ever.
This is exactly what we're terrified of,
what we see happening in Paris and in
other parts of the world.
And here we have an American doing it.
And our differentiation is not even
that,
you know,
we're,
we're being attacked the way we're
looking at it in terms of its white
people and white nationalists versus
empty,
right?
We're not even looking at it like we're
all Americans.
all on the same team.
We're,
we're,
we're literally homegrown terrorism.
That's a homegrown terrorist activity.
Yeah.
One hundred percent,
100 percent.
I mean,
so you worried about al Qaeda,
you're worried about isis,
you're worried about the Taliban.
You've got something right here that is
willing to drive a car into a random
group of people that look just like him,
a bunch of white people.
I mean,
this is,
this is completely fucking insane.
And the craziest part is they're not
doing it to overthrow like the yolk of
empire.
It's not like,
like,
you know,
the,
uh,
Ireland back in the seventies with
British control,
like at least you can kind of be like,
oh,
they don't want to be controlled by the.
So these people are literally living in
the most free country.
You know,
they're prosperous to the point of
almost boredom where they start.
And I don't think Antifa realizes how
much similarity they have to the people
they claim to be fighting against.
It's a natural progression to have
extremely violent protests like these
people happen.
Everybody ramps it up,
they ramp it up in the left,
they ramp it up in the right,
everybody gets angry in this fucking
asshole drives into a bunch of people.
Fuck man,
it's fucking awful.
And then trump said,
here's the thing.
All this happened because we were taking
down the statue of Robert e Dot Lee,
who's the leader of the confederates,
right?
Trump literally say said today,
what's next?
Are we going to take down a statue of
George Washington?
It's like,
what?
It's a bit of a false equivalency of
How the fuck can you even say that?
That this is.
He's got some weird thing going on,
were asked to dance around his support
for white supremacists or white
nationalist.
He has to dance around it,
which is weird because they're not that
big of a group like it's not like.
But if they're on your side,
they're all on your side.
10,000
people and it might be a lot more than
you think.
Man might be a lot of closet racists out
there.
I see so much similarities between like,
you know,
white racist and then like the social
justice racists or it's like it's just,
it's usually like the white Nazis or
like the losers trying to get something
out of their skin and then social
justice worries.
A lot of times they're trying to get
something out of an oppressed,
being an unoppressed status in both of
those groups.
I'm like,
you're both trying to avoid merit,
merit.
Like you're just trying to get something
from your stupid group because he never
see like a Nazi is like good looking,
are successful.
They're always just like,
I deserve some shit because I'm white.
And you're like,
then that means you're weak as fuck.
I think it was,
I just think it's just a massive failure
from the beginning to now of thinking a
similar thing that makes sense to me.
Yeah,
and just like the agenda,
thank where it's like you start ignoring
basic reality to get clicks or you know,
outrage culture as well.
It's just the.
It's just not the way to go.
You did see matt just joined up with all
white people like that.
It's just insane.
It's completely insane and even the
concept of white is a new concept,
but growing up it's like,
oh,
you're Irish or Italian,
or it's like one of this fucking
federation kickoff.
Well,
we've been forced in this position by a
thing called white privilege.
I don't know if you're aware of it.
I checked it on my way on check yourself
before you wreck yourself.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing is we're all human
beings who migrated from Africa.
That's a fact.
I go back far enough,
but we don't.
We're not willing to go back farther.
We're like,
we're stopping wherever the fuck.
I know we've got this accident from a
dcs my homeland and defendant defendant
acted in my deaf.
That guy's just that color because it
never fucking.
It's always.
It's always cloudy.
You have vitamin ever stops raining.
It's literally it.
Exactly.
That's why they're so pale.
They're trying to suck as much of the
Vitamin d out of the sky as they can.
Yeah,
cause like two percent couldn't get
pussy because they died.
They died and that's how vitamin D and
that's an evolution works.
They turn it into paper.
Those people to just did little goddamn
solar panels just walking around,
sucking in.
The vitamin D take it is.
They're all Africans.
Irish people are Africans that just
stayed in Ireland.
Yes.
That's what we all are.
It's just like a flash when we started
separating and it really has nothing to
do with who we are as people.
I can see the criticism.
Oh,
you're one of those bro.
I don't see color people.
Those people.
I don't even see color pro.
Maybe be like,
no,
I,
I am racist,
but listen,
I don't want you in my store but I know
are equal except with the gay rainbow.
Yeah.
Just so I'm not in the raiders fans or
you know,
a Chinese food shoppers.
Yeah.
Like I used to do a song where it's like
black dudes with more than one pit bull
scare the shit out of me.
But a black guy with a cell phone on his
belt I trust.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
I would do it.
I would have the crowd.
He works at Verizon because it's all
cultural signifiers and so I would have
the crowd yell out anybody,
you know,
white people like white dudes with tear
drop tattoos in Idaho,
scared,
you know,
and you just go through any race and
you're like,
look,
it's always,
it's that Chris Rock joke that I won't
repeat because of my,
my privileged,
but like there's this group and then
there's this Chris and everybody knows
which one are the dickheads in which
one,
not even dickheads,
but from a position of like desperation.
Yeah.
Depending on where you are in history.
If I walk by too many dudes that have
their pants sagging,
so like more than two of them are,
oh,
these guys must make stupid decisions.
Yeah.
Bad decision guys.
If you got like your,
your pants,
like down to like duck curve,
the downward curve or your ass.
Right?
It's riding the curve and I could see
like a giant percentage of your
underwear.
Yeah.
One guy may have forgot about two guys.
They're heightened guns.
Just not even that.
It's just they're just making stupid
decisions with their life.
Sure.
My brother judges people based on if
they back into their spot or not.
Oh.
If they can know.
My brother's like that got in back end,
doesn't give a shit about his family and
he'll make fucking jumped.
He's like,
oh,
so are then.
And if someone needs them,
I just back in in case of emergencies.
He's like,
that is a good move.
Actually.
He's right.
But like it's just intensity,
like judge people on that.
Yeah.
But like I'm,
I'm getting out.
If I can back out,
like I'll still get it.
Like how much of an advantage I'd like
to see,
like a test that shows how much,
how much of an advantage you have in a
dangerous situation and a half second.
Like was he being attacked by like a
pterodactyl look at?
Probably a whole second.
Let me think back.
And then you take off.
He'd probably have like a good solid two
or three seconds probably.
Yeah,
that could save is.
Yeah.
You know,
why you might be able to make a light or
you know,
like,
yeah,
my below figure out like someone's
falling off a cliff and was just like,
that's like two seconds.
Yeah.
But I guess it,
yeah,
if you're in a dangerous situation,
then the real question is like,
how dangerous are we talking?
Do you have to decide like,
do you want to be one of those people
that survives nuclear holocaust or do
you want to be one of those people that
dies?
And the initial blast alone death,
uh,
with my friends and family,
Po,
po survive if I was alone.
Like if it was that,
that like,
uh,
the,
the road,
that book.
Yeah.
I didn't want,
I didn't read that book,
but I watched a little bit of the movie
up until he was teaching.
His son were to shoot himself in the
mouth to kill himself and.
Yeah,
and I was like,
check please.
That's in high stake.
Shit.
I'm good.
Yeah,
I would've.
I would've went out with the blast.
It just seems like you don't want to
cannibalize.
You just don't stay alive.
You really don't.
You just don't know.
You don't.
You don't want to have to worry about
people eating.
You either feel.
I'm scared of the owls.
Like right now.
Imagine if you're constantly under
threat of someone's stealing everything
that you have.
Constantly.
Constant.
Yeah.
You're up in the middle of the night.
Check cocked and ready to rock looking
out the window.
Always worried about invaders that might
eat you.
I lost a bunch of chickens to raccoon
and a Fox recently and it dawned on me
that stakes of life where I'm like,
if I needed those eggs,
like I'm fucking dead.
You killed nine of them in one night.
Jesus Christ.
And I was like,
one mistake,
one hole in the thing,
and they drink the blood.
Right?
Is that what they do?
The raccoons,
they bite their neck and drink their
blood.
I think so they took the bodies.
They did.
Yeah.
So that's why I think there's a fox
involved.
Oh No.
Yeah.
Wow.
There's a whole party going on your
chicken.
It was crazy.
So we stayed up the next night with air
rifles and shot a raccoon and a Fox
because they came back.
Oh,
they did?
It was like a Disney movie.
Goddamn.
Um,
air rifle.
Huh?
Wilcon.
Uh,
I just want you to get it like ace
hardware.
Store one.
Yeah.
So did it kill them or just hurt?
I was just trying to set a tone.
Like I wasn't looking to take them out.
I was looking to do like,
listen,
don't kill the girls.
Interesting.
Because.
Because I can't legally shoot a gun in
my area even though I'm in the country.
Time to go walking dead style son.
Get yourself across both.
Yeah.
I gotta go,
but I'm not accurate yet.
Yeah,
that's the problem.
It takes a long time to learn how to get
accurate with a boat.
I would recommend a crossbow and nice
rest with a crossbow is basically a
shitty gun.
It's a gun that shoots bolts.
I mean it just doesn't.
It's not really a bow.
I mean it's.
You're going to trigger.
All you have to do is squeeze that
sucker off and put the crosshairs on it
and they fly really flat and really
fast.
You can fuck up a Fox with one of those
if you were so inclined.
I am inclined.
Well,
Kelly,
your chickens,
you should definitely try to scare it
off and there's other options too.
They can.
You can take a urine.
They'll sell like mountain lion urine
and even wolf urine testing on it
doesn't work like vitamins and.
Oh,
he eats bananas big.
He's been drunk for a week.
I think he's.
He's so dehydrated.
He's not gonna do anything.
Yeah.
If you have like a different kinds of
animals that get scared off by different
kinds of sense.
Yeah.
I gotta get a cent.
We man get some.
Both pis,
they sell the shit they do.
They really sell it,
they sell all kinds of different animal
pis to ward off other animals.
It's really interesting.
Clock Piss.
Um,
I don't think that works.
I don't think it works with raptors.
So I think it's more of a mammal thing.
Raptors piss on stuff.
That'd be interesting if they did.
I know mammals do.
Dogs and cats piss on shit.
Mark their ground.
Yeah.
Because it's like birds are like raptors
to use that word just changed my whole
opinion out there.
Fucking gangster there.
So there are so predatory there.
So ruthless to.
Yeah.
I used to work at a dock and I'd feed
ducks a brad and just watched them
fucking destroyed job.
Bite each others stealing bread from
each other.
That's why when a girl does a duck face
instinctively granted.
Um,
so,
uh,
let's come back to that Google memo
thing.
Yeah.
Because this is one of the weird lines
in the sand that got cross with this is
that uh,
everybody,
I mean everybody established a line in
the sand I should say.
And it was like you thought that memo
was the worst thing you've ever read
ever.
And that guy's a massage and a piece of
shit,
or he said,
well,
yeah,
evolutionary psychology sort of tries to
explain why,
why people choose certain things and
like what factors,
what factors or environmental factors or
hormonal would,
what factors have to do with being a
male when have,
female.
And there's like a lot of studies and
that guy cited a lot of studies and he
talked like he.
It was a really interesting thing.
The only thing that I think people could
find derogatory maybe is that he said
the women are more neurotic.
Neurotic is sort of a derogatory term,
right?
I'm actually a derogatory term.
Right.
It's not neurotic is saying that you're
not handling something good.
Right.
You're not,
you're not handling whatever
pressures.
Yeah.
There's a neurotic.
Right.
I would be calm because it's implying
that you,
the another person handling that same
situation,
perhaps even mail that'd be more calm.
Right.
Like the like very aware would be the
nice way of saying it because I like,
my wife has a lot of anxiety,
but once we had a baby I was like,
oh,
this is why because you're responsible
for this,
like little alien,
it can die.
Totally make sense.
But the thing that guy said that,
that the car,
like when,
when people would argue with me about
it,
I'd be like,
so do you think men and women are the
same?
And from there I don't care if they're
an expert,
if they say there is no difference at
all.
I'm like,
my mom had her phd and quit to raise us
as soon as she had her baby and my wife
stays home with our son was an engineer.
It's like that isn't saying that there
aren't rockstar female engineers that
have no interest in having a child.
All it does is affect the,
uh,
the percentage.
And that's always saying is equality of
outcome versus a opportunity is really
the debate.
And I'm very against equality of outcome
because the legal precedent,
that is insane.
A real issue.
Like you have to find out,
okay,
what is the actual suppression?
What is stopping people from getting to
this position that happened?
Be Female?
Is it because they're being suppressed
along the way?
Is it because the way they interact with
each other is different than the way men
interact with each other and so when men
interact with them,
they get upset by it.
There's different rules that have to be
established in these working
environments.
Is it that they don't want to have
anything to do with that and they would
rather not compete in one of those
hostile male driven environments?
Is that why they choose not to get
involved or are they someone stopping
them?
If someone's saying,
hey,
we gotta keep chicks out here.
I don't like checks.
Like it would completely depend on
what's actually happening if the ladders
happening,
but then you got a real issue.
Exactly,
but if the former like the very
beginning one,
if they choose different stuff,
ironically it hurts women the most.
Like the very qualified ones with the
job.
People start looking at him.
I go because they're women,
even though like programming itself was
founded by a chick,
you know,
but like I don't think that she vented
Cobol,
right?
Yeah.
Like some of my buddies.
So I was going on that one.
It's called cobol the lovelace.
Oh yeah.
It's like,
it's not discluding and it's not saying
that women can't do it.
Of course less women are interested in
doing it.
Yes.
So if you have an equal number of men
and women,
then you probably go like artificially
inflated the number of women.
Yes.
That makes sense.
Unless for some reason women gravitate
towards that thing and just as higher
percentages men do,
which is really odd because not a lot of
things where women gravitate towards it
with the same percentage of people.
It's the same like,
like,
like there's,
I'm sure there's a lot of fields of
study.
I know particularly nursing and I think
a lot of the social studies that women
gravitate tape towards in higher
numbers.
Right?
Like,
like nursing,
healthcare even I think he teaching
children's,
I think there's more female physicians
means that's bullshit.
Maybe I read that from some.
You're like teaching children gravitate
more to.
There's got to be a ton of different
jobs that females like gravitate towards
in higher percentages.
We,
we absolutely shouldn't insist that
there's an equal representation of men
in florists.
Exactly.
And then you know,
in,
in interior design.
My brother's a lumberjack.
We worked,
we worked with one woman worked with us
one time and she was from Yale and like
probably doing a whole thing,
you know,
like he couldn't,
well I dunno,
but couldn't climb a tree and like some
women for sure could,
but if you're going like these dudes go
up 200 foot trees and,
and spend all day like chopping them
down,
it's like,
that isn't going to drop 50 percent
women.
It just isn't.
Here's what's the most hilarious thing
about the google memo.
It upset so many women that they had to
take time off proving the point.
It's so crazy.
They wanted time off so bad that they
went for it.
They want to play the victim so hard
that they went for it and not even
understanding that it proves the point
of the most skeptical people,
the most skeptical people on the side of
like,
I don't know if these chicks are going
to be able to pull their own weight,
these chicks,
and then immediately they encounter any
adversity like we need time off from a
memo.
Handle this from a nice.
Somebody talked about evolutionary
psychology and I just can't handle it.
I need time away from work.
I'm being attacked
because they said it was time for a
female James Bond.
Oh,
like I called him.
I called her double o seven,
seven cents on the dollar and one of the
jobs,
Jane Bond,
she's open to hyphenation and then
whether lies is in need of a big Asian.
That's so funny.
It's like if you take James,
you can have a female spy.
It's just going to be different tactics.
You can't have a male wonder woman.
Okay,
okay.
We can have a female James Bond.
Make your own fucking detective.
Be James Bond.
He's a guy and I'm cool with Black
Santa.
I am too,
because that's because that's I think
Megan Kelly was out of line.
I do too.
She was out a lot,
but theoretically why the fuck would he
be black?
Who was living up in the North Pole?
It'd be white as shit.
That's the whole point.
The Irish magic.
There's no god damn sign up there.
It's freezing cold.
Yeah.
Black gets outside.
There could be black Santa but he would
die of rickets.
Well,
I don't think that would be the case,
but I think he would,
uh,
he would have a real issue getting some
vitamin D.
He would,
he'd have to go get it somewhere.
Maybe some supplements.
Spine and get all fucked up telling them
elves hooked me up.
Dude.
You know when you're building a little
toy trains and shit,
they'll be some fucking vitamin D bitch.
The d,
The dls.
Use that Christmas magic.
Right?
Like make Sanderson Vitamin D.
I can't work deep breath.
Yeah.
And then they always bring,
bring.
They bring blow too because San has got
to step for two straight days.
Santa does adderall like crazy.
Rampages listens to techno only house
music wise.
Manga toys to crunch times like you
know,
all through Decembers,
frantic pop adderall.
Cancel A.
Yeah.
And then and then like.
And everyone's like,
why are the presidents alphabetical?
He's like,
fuck,
I got to be off a better go organized.
He over organized Santa went crazy.
Crazy.
But yeah,
it's like if you say that there has to
be an equal outcome,
you're going to sacrifice quality of
wondered what jobs there would be where
you have.
If you have 100 men,
100 women,
one,
what jobs would you have to be where you
had an equal number of men in equal
number of women that are interested in
those jobs out of 100.
Like what job would that be?
What do you think would be other than
like famous,
I want to be famous.
What about high school teacher?
I feel like we're on family feud.
I'll go to the Richard Dawson family
feud by the way.
No disrespect Steve Harvey.
I remember Steve Dawson.
Saturdays as that guy.
Always kind of like,
grabbed a little drunk.
Yeah,
he'd like put his hands on people.
You'd be like,
there's only 15 of those.
Hey,
here's the PR guy.
He was in a fucking Nazi comedy.
He was a god Damn Nazi county.
He was in Hogan's heroes.
Oh yeah,
that's God.
Damn.
Nazi got less than 30 years after the
war.
Right.
It's like,
I love Lucy,
but Auschwitz,
like,
what's that pitch like?
Let's ask the question.
What year do you think Hogan's heroes
came out?
I want to say it was in the seventies
and the war ended in 47.
Correct.
When was Hogan's heroes?
Sixty five.
Holy Shit.
Holy Shit,
dude.
That's less than 20 years after the war
was over.
They had a goddamn comedy about the war.
Do you think that's gallows humor,
like it affected so many people that
they had this impulse to market?
Well,
I think people were tougher back then
for sure.
They could joke around about shit more.
Hence Archie bunker to be literally
impossible to have today.
The amount of outrage if someone tried
to make an art,
a character like archie bunker.
Yeah,
good.
Oh,
look at that.
He was wearing a fucking.
Remember he had to pretend to be a Nazi
at one point in time snuck in.
There's a,
there's so much hard today,
so much anger at even racist characters
in fiction.
If you have a racist character in
fiction,
people are angry you like there's a
bunch of young,
what's young fiction like young heart
and there's a um,
there's a category that they use,
but there's this very popular book and
it's being attacked by all these social
justice warriors because of this one
character that's racist.
And so someone took the,
the racist quotes at this character set
and took him completely out of context,
out of the context of the book and
published it in a blog and was saying
like,
look at this racist bullshit that's in
this book.
And then people are getting really mad
at the course.
They never read the book,
read the blog,
which is what people do.
And so they got super fucking mad and
it,
it just became this huge thing.
Like,
wait a minute,
you're saying you can't have a monster
in a book and you have a guy who's a
murderer?
Because if we can't do that,
I need to know where the fucking line
is.
Man Can.
I can't,
I can't make a book about a serial
killer.
Oh,
I can.
Okay.
But it can't be racist.
Right?
Oh,
got it.
Okay.
Can I make a book about a guy who brings
people back from the dead and they kill
a bunch of people and can I do that?
I can.
Okay.
But he can't be racist.
You can't discriminate against Chinese
people.
Can't discriminate.
I've used the wrong pronoun.
It doesn't matter.
Imagine how fucking stupid you have to
be that it would just be clock,
which right now be called Dr Jekyll
like,
Fred,
if you forget,
hide,
you don't learn.
Like,
like,
um,
my mom was teaching a class once a and
she was like,
they took Edward Jim out of huckleberry
Finn.
Yeah,
they did get that word out.
You can't know at time unless you know
the characters from that time,
you know,
and it's giving people a real disservice
to just like emasculate and neuter our
history so that everybody can't see what
real dangers are.
Like what just happened in
Charlottesville,
like all the people that called Dave
Rubin and Nazi now to use the same word
for these people right now it has no
meaning.
Exactly.
Good.
Very good point.
Thank you.
It's a.
it's really important to not overreact
to people that don't have the exact same
opinion as you.
Now when something like this happens,
you realize,
okay,
that's what you should react to.
Exactly.
This is real.
You got a bunch of Douche bags with a
fucking with torches from home depot or
wherever the fuck they got this.
Those are those Citronella court people
have been like the suburbs.
They have like a Tiki party by some and
now I can't come on because literally
kind of like I liked those torches for
killing mosquitoes and I was thinking
about it.
I'm like,
I'm not going to buy those now because
of Charlottesville and all these guys.
I mean,
if,
if any of those people that are into
that are listening,
I'm not even upset at you as a human,
you get trapped into patterns of
thinking.
I'm upset at that pattern.
I'm upset that this is a repeated
repeating pattern that's happened
through human history where people
decide that there's specific groups that
somehow or another deserved preferential
treatment or are better or or or or
superior or should dominate over other
groups.
It's stupid and it's bad for business.
It's bad for the business of being human
beings.
It gets in the way.
You're.
You're judging people and nonsense and
you get to all be in the group just
because you have similar skin color
that's fucking stupid.
You're allowing a bunch of losers in
your group then because you're.
The only differentiation is that they
have to be white.
That is insanely stupid.
It's so stupid,
so don't miss out on all the cool black
people you're going to miss out on all
the cool Cubans and all the cool Puerto
Rican.
You're going gonna miss out on them and
you're gonna.
You're gonna.
Think that you have some family in this
idea that you all have nordic routes or
something like that.
It's so dumb.
It's.
I understand if you run into people that
are black and they're racist against
white people and you feel like you know,
white people have to protect themselves.
If you get one of those situations and
those situations are real,
they can happen.
Racism can occur on both sides and this
another disingenuous thing that the left
is doing is accepting this idea that you
can only be racist if you're white.
It's just a racist statement.
It's so racist.
It's over,
but this is something that people were.
I think they've kind of let it go for
for most recently,
like out there in the twitter sphere,
but for a good long time it was a
defensible argument that a black person
couldn't be racist because racism is all
about power and black people don't have
power over white people.
Like what's that?
That is,
you're changing the word.
You're changing the fucking word and
you're going to empower actual racist
course and it's like no one,
you don't know Nazis till you know,
treaty of Versailles and you don't know
this until like,
you know,
just over shaming always has a
springboard effect.
Like I'll wait like after world war one,
it's the same with like,
you know that shamed gay guys,
the one that hates gay people,
you know,
where it's like shame is a horrible
thing and people and so world war one
blood on our hands,
you know,
that was started and executed for very
bizarre reasons.
They blamed Germany for all of it to the
point where they destroyed Germany and
then they were looking for a voice.
It gave them hope and that voice is
insane.
And so that happens.
That happened in this where it's like,
dear white people being white.
You should just say sorry all the
fucking time.
Even though your people came in 19.
Oh,
you know,
well you can see it today.
And the people that never criticized
trump and have like exclamation points
and the right Magda after all their
tweets,
no matter what trump does,
no matter what trump says,
it's always amazing.
Everything is always perfect.
Like,
okay,
well I see what you're doing because
you're not really thinking right.
Really thinking you,
you,
you gotTa fucking team your go raiders.
Let's go.
Raiders your let's go.
Trump like,
well now this is not,
this is not healthy,
this is not a normal way to discuss
super important issues.
Just wouldn't.
Trump said today that like,
what's next?
They're going to take down the statue of
George Washington.
It was like they took down a statue of
Robert e Dot Lee and every freaking
what's next?
We're going to take down the statue of
George Washington.
You're like,
what?
Yeah.
That's like when the word normalizing
actually fits,
you know,
like all these things that have been so
flooded that is normalizing something
terrible,
but it's like so crazy competitive and
with Robert e Dot Lee is actually a
problem,
but the left is like over pointed out
problems to the point where knowing like
you can't have your,
you don't trust your instincts right now
where you're like,
if I say this,
does this make me racist?
It's like what?
That it's 80 degrees outside.
How is that linked?
You know?
And also I think anybody coming in and
deciding to do something is a problem.
You know,
like people coming in and started
deciding to take down a statue.
Statues assembled to a lot of people and
a lot of people step in and say,
hey,
this is it.
I think there should be some sort of
real prolonged,
intelligent conversation about what that
statute means and have it in a way we're
a bunch of people can,
can see it and have it represented on
both sides have been represented by the
side of people that think it's a good
idea to keep it up and have it
represented on the side of someone who
thinks it's a good idea to move on and
maybe we should take this thing and put
it in some sort of a war museum and not
having it represent the goddamn
confederate soldiers in the middle of
this town that's not confederate.
Okay.
We.
The war's gone because you're.
You're holding on to this idea that your
team lost a battle and that there's an
invading army that sitting with you.
Right?
I know.
We're all Americans.
Okay.
This is old,
old,
old shit.
18 60 shit.
Okay,
let it go stupid.
Let's take this down and let's put up a
goddamn glorious kid.
Rock Tattoo Style Eagle with a fucking
flag behind it.
Come out.
Really Love America.
Let's take down the Robert e Dot Lee and
put up hulking American Eagle with a
fucking flag in the wind.
Just cash and then underneath it have a
gigantic plaque of everybody that lost
their lives in the last two wars over
the last 20 years.
Have that.
Yeah.
I think a lot of it is how it's being
represented to.
Is it like a glorious statue or is it
just a relic of history?
Because I think the debate is a seen it.
No,
I haven't either.
Let's look at it.
Find out what's The statue of Robert e
Lee that they were taking down.
I'm curious.
Let me see.
Oh,
what if he was found out?
He was like banging a slave.
Oh,
that's it.
Torch wielding protesters.
Rally confederate statute.
Yeah.
Can we go a large on that bunny?
Wow.
That's beautiful.
Piece of art.
You know,
I mean,
much like when you look at [inaudible]
con,
it's a beautiful piece of art.
You know,
you look at some of the statues and
things that they constructed from back
in his day.
You let you think about it.
You Go,
wow,
this was a guy at war.
Yeah.
Who killed like a fit,
like five percent of the earth.
Yeah,
something even crazier.
I think he killed like 10 percent of the
world's population while he was alive.
Yeah.
This is a tough one because this one,
because that is a rebel army we lost.
So that should be taken down,
but at the same time it's like,
but what do you do with.
And then to the natives,
Americans tell people to take down in
Washington,
you know,
then you start,
then you start getting in a battle of
like,
well this person wronged my people.
Well this person.
And then you,
you know,
like I see people with Che shirts from
urban outfitters and I'm like,
that dude committed genocide.
Do a lot of people,
you know.
And it's like,
at what point is it with this one?
I think that it's a valid argument to
take it down because it was a rebel army
and well I'm just a rebel army in the
country that it's still in,
but at the same time it's like it's a
slippery slope of a racing.
Right.
You know?
Well,
I don't think you should have it in your
state capital,
wherever the fuck that.
Is that what it is?
State Capitol building.
Oh,
that's a no brainer.
Yeah.
Represents that state what it is,
but see if he could pull it up again
just so we know what the fuck we're
talking about.
I think that was kind of like.
I think it was like a state building.
Look,
it was a big deal.
That's how I felt about confederate
flag.
I'm like,
obviously take it off state buildings.
Justice is still a part of a few
different flags.
Right.
That's that to me crosses that line
where you're like,
oh,
well now you're incorporating it into
the government that a lot of people
associate with like valid social issues.
I mean,
to this day,
I think it's on Mississippi's.
That's very intense.
Yeah.
Emancipation park in front of their
courthouse in front of the courthouse.
Wow,
man.
That's,
that's a bit of a tone.
You can't do that.
I mean,
you got to get that guy out of there.
Look,
I think for sure we should keep it.
I mean,
I don't think they should destroy it.
Just like,
I don't think they should destroy,
you know,
if there's a statue of mouse somewhere,
I don't think they should destroy it.
I think we should.
We should look at it and hold onto it so
that future generations can look back
and go,
wow,
that's possible.
The Berlin Wall it a little pieces to be
like,
yeah,
that people fucking the world into at
one point.
And if we forget that we started doing
this live action role play until someone
gets hit by a car,
it's like,
yeah,
well we
better.
Right?
So we want better.
And so we pretend that better.
We're already exists or is possible if
we force people to behave the way we
want.
Right.
You know,
there's a bunch of different ways where
people try to achieve better,
you know,
and they're not all smart because a lot
of them are based on how you feel right
now and what you want to change.
So you try to be forceful,
but like the bounce back thing we're
talking about,
it doesn't really work like that when
you,
when you push too hard at people and you
don't respect them,
um,
even if there is ridiculous as a white
nationalist,
when you push push at them.
And why do I say it's ridiculous if
you're asking because it's all
ridiculous.
I think being a black nationalist is
ridiculous too.
I think it's all ridiculous.
I think you should be a human being and
it just because you enjoy black culture,
it doesn't mean you have to be racist.
You can enjoy Chinese people just as
much.
We can all just be cool with each other.
But this idea that there's like one
superior race is insane.
We are all interconnected in some very
bizarre way and we help each other.
And that's what culture is.
That's what civilization is.
The reason why it all works so well is
that we're all intertwined with each
other,
learning from each other,
trying to figure out how to navigate
this thing together,
competing with each other,
improving upon a whatever the fuck it is
we're working on because of the
competition from all sorts of different
parts of the world,
different cultures and behavior patterns
and levels of aggression,
levels of intellect and all of us
combined and some sort of a swarming
soup of innovation and ideas and
communication and trying to figure this
thing out together and as soon as you
just lump it all up to white people only
like get the fuck Outta here with that
old stupid idea.
That's a stupid idea.
Yeah,
and that's why I'm so anti pc and
cultural appropriation stuff because
those are the mechanisms to share.
Yeah.
It's like the.
It's not because I'm white and I don't
want people to get credit for whatever
they do it.
It's saying,
how do we know?
There's no quote that when goods,
when good stop going across borders,
armies go across borders where it's like
if see cultures coming together and
sharing and developing and everything
you just said is necessary for
multiculturalism,
and so if you say,
I can't wear some bro because I'm a
white guy,
he's no good.
Even though I'm,
you know,
stupid.
As long as you're not being an asshole
about it,
you just have fun and what's the big
deal and who needs that?
Brim white guys pedals.
Fuck right.
And we have a nice dark complexion.
They can handle it.
I know Jews have no brim dude.
Very good.
Very important point.
Mexicans and juices with that,
with some of the Super Orthodox ones,
they have the crazy brim,
right?
Yeah.
They're like cheese heads with for.
Oh,
that's a different one,
right?
That's a different one.
That's a different kind of hat they
were.
I've seen that one.
Yeah,
that's a weird one.
It's like part of West Hollywood has a
bunch of those hats.
Yeah,
that's an interesting thing.
Yeah.
Hollywood,
when you drive,
there's certain neighborhoods you go
down to the all orthodox Jews or at
least a high volume of them.
You see them with their strings that
hang down from their belt.
Totally.
Fear used to rock those,
those things.
Oh yeah.
He had the whole whole garb.
But that's so intense.
Those dudes are.
There's the hat she's had with that is
some ancient shit that that culture is
clinging to his bananas.
When do they say no?
More like,
you know what year they like,
all right,
we're 18.
15 guys.
Well as long as you can keep together.
I mean this is a nice representation of
what we're talking about.
Non Integration,
you know,
if you keep together in your own little
community and only cohabitate with your
own,
you keep this thing going as long as you
can and that's what they're doing right
now.
That's the irony of lack of oppression
sometimes.
I was talking to these gay dudes in
Houston recently and there are like
almost bummed that there,
like everyone loves gay people so much
because they don't feel as unified.
Like we used to have a bar and I'm like,
you can still have the bar man.
He's just now have the bravo channel to.
Yeah,
but guys go in the bar now.
Like straight guys.
We're going to gay bars and girls.
Girls fucking love gay bars.
You go to gay bars and that's why
straight guys go there sometimes because
girls together,
it just for gas bar straight guys like
they fucking weasel in on gay girls are
drunk,
drunk straight girls rather.
They do it.
They're like,
it doesn't even matter if you touch it.
I don't even feel anything.
I don't feel shit.
Even when I'm coming I don't feel it.
Or it also shows that they're so open
minded.
He goes to the gay bar.
I love that.
He's so confident.
Yeah.
And women will go.
They're vulnerable sometimes,
so it's like,
it's like I've just gotTa have a
relationship and I want to just talk and
not be hit on because I'm so vulnerable.
And then some dudes like it woke up my
fanny pack.
There's a duke in it.
You also have any bags by the way.
It's like that a Mickey Rourke game that
he did in a diner.
Remember the movie diner?
He put his Dick through the hole in the
bottom,
the bottom of the bucket of popcorn.
See bed,
his friend that you'd grab his dick and
he's like no fucking way.
And He,
so he put his dick through the popcorn
and then like as soon as she reached in
and grabbed it,
wow.
But what if she didn't realize it was
his dick and just pulled up,
was yanked it and broke it off like,
uh,
like when you were hanging off that
chimpanzee.
There it is.
There's a scene that's back when we can
work as a beautiful man.
Can you imagine that scene now?
Yeah.
Those skills just kind of say it's rape.
That's essentially rape.
I mean,
you can't do that.
You can't,
you can't force someone to be intimate
with you and trick them if you're,
if someone's intimate with you,
don't even play that on this show.
God Damn it.
This is rape culture.
He's shut that off right now.
Too Hot.
Yeah.
Like when I was a kid,
it was so different that I have to train
myself to not be like,
you should see how crazy chicken get.
Right?
Like there used to be dudes just
whacking off in the street.
It was like weird.
They really started dudes walking off in
the street.
Well there was one dude in the middle
school woods would just chase everyone
wagon off and it was like,
you tell your parents,
like you tell your parents and your
parents were like,
yeah,
you can brush that one off.
It's not.
They're crushed that one off.
That was actual wiener right there.
And yet there's a lot of drama in this
movie.
It's a slow burn.
People wouldn't even have time for that
today.
People are so twitter fied everybody's
child.
There she goes,
she grabbed it and she's mad and she got
up to leave.
Bam.
She's outraged.
But then when you pull the wean out,
all the popcorn is falls in your lap.
Yeah.
You got to be.
Watch this.
Here it goes.
She's going to grab.
That was really subtly good.
Acting like he was like,
whoa.
It terrible.
Oh yeah.
I really liked it.
The editing was bad,
just obviously to texts to two
different.
That'd get a lot of coverage.
I was like,
this happened,
but this happened before this app.
It was.
Why are you showing that?
Like that?
Weird.
It's like we got to get plenty of
coverage.
I almost had a replay.
Like a half a second replay.
Yeah,
man.
Um,
you can't do that anymore.
Couldn't have that in the movie now
probably for good.
I don't know.
But I know I'm wrestling with that too.
If it's fiction,
right?
There are people like that that can
exist.
Like we were talking about murderers.
Are you allowed to have monsters and
murderers.
Are you allowed to show movies about
war?
Okay.
Well,
if you are,
how come you can have a rapist in a
movie but you obviously can we use it in
good taste?
Is it something people want to see
whole?
Won't the market dictate that?
You know,
like,
I don't.
I don't know if you should be able to
say that we're allowed to have murders
in a movie,
but we're not allowed to have rapists.
Yeah.
It's got to be market.
I feel like I don't want to see people
get raped,
but I don't know that you should be able
to tell someone they can't do that or
they can't write it out.
Then it always ends bad.
That's the draw socialism.
It's narcissism where someone goes,
if I had control,
everyone would be better.
And then even if that guy's awesome,
the next guy styling.
Well,
that's the thing is like these,
these kind of like we're talking about
the statute,
having a long conversation.
Like you have to have conversations
about this kind of shit.
Like should you want to read about rape?
Oh,
of course not.
But should you be able to put whatever
the fuck you want into whatever it is
that it's your,
your,
um,
your creation.
I mean,
you're sitting there and you're writing
out a story that you're manipulating
with your imagination.
You're putting it all together.
You should be able to have horrific
characters that everyone is terrified of
that people trying to get away from.
If that includes rapists or murderers or
whoever the fuck it is.
If you're trying to tell a terrifying
tale and a book,
you can't be hindered,
you can't be stopped.
Like we have to be really careful about
what,
what we're saying here.
Well,
we're submitting will to someone that
doesn't have our best interests.
That's what it is.
Because they don't.
No one really cares that much.
I don't think they care,
but I don't think they're thinking.
I think it's more of a,
not thinking about this like it doesn't,
just because someone has a book about
rapist doesn't mean people are going to
rape more because like if there's a book
about,
you know,
people that are murderers and I'm going
to go out and murder more,
you know,
that's.
I don't,
I don't believe that that's valid.
I think when you talking about fiction,
um,
and
again,
I don't want to read about it,
but I don't want you to be able to tell
people that they can't write about
certain things.
That seems to me like way over the line,
like way over the line.
Yeah.
Because then you can't do critical
government stuff.
It's the legal precedent that set that
then makes the craziest shit possible
where it's like,
oh,
this is a words are violence.
These words are violence.
I'm raped now.
No one can say like,
our new president is horrible.
You know,
like now you can't even show descent.
It's all just a way to tighten the
screws.
Don't you think that people in the left
or show showing dissent more than like a
violent descent towards the president,
like really like,
angry,
like in a way that I can't remember
anybody doing towards Obama now to the
point where it freaks me out.
Like they're like,
it's weird.
Well,
I didn't,
I wasn't obviously traveling in the
right circles.
Look for people that really angry at
Obama,
but even the people that I saw online
that are angry and um,
they were calling them and competent or
food.
We're spending all of our money and all
this different accusations,
but not like what I'm seeing with trump.
Like I'm seeing just like flat out
insults from famous people all the time.
Yeah.
And the media,
I don't get why people totally trust
immediate.
It's like you'll see them misrepresent
something in such an egregious way and
my dad is a rhetoric professor,
so it's like he teaches a class in
propaganda.
This is like my whole childhood is
learning about the shit.
I'm watching CNN.
I'm like,
you motherfuckers,
you know exactly like you can
misrepresent things so egregiously that
I'm like,
of course no one's going to trust you
and that's a real problem.
Right,
and it's not that you.
You don't wish that they were correct,
right?
It's that in them lying.
Even if you're on their side more than
you're on the Fox News,
CNN lies even a little.
Then it's fuel for the other side and it
vastly diminishes the impact that you
can have because you're not.
You're not trustworthy anymore.
That's all you have in news now is
trustworthiness because everyone can
manipulate and photoshop.
Now that,
that,
that Audio Photoshop,
oh my God.
It's like you have to just trust people.
I can't trust anybody though.
It's real issue and an issue with an
issue with the left being so hyperbolic.
It's like when trump was first elected,
I was like,
ah,
sucks.
Trump's crazy,
and then I saw their reaction and almost
like triaged it and I was like,
wait a minute,
what's crazier?
The guy that may like texted dictator is
Dick,
or like people like saying that
democracy is bad and I'm like,
this is a weird battle.
Well,
it's certainly not the result that
people wanted,
right?
Like a lot of people.
And so having him there,
they're super frustrated and all the
things that they see happening,
people are super frustrated and they
don't know what to do.
And so,
um,
the,
the feeling is that you should somehow
under the protest and riot and like the
people that got in front of trump tower
because of his reaction to
Charlottesville,
people are super upset at his reaction.
That was,
I think that was a big one when he said
that,
you know,
that something about despicable acts of
violence on
all sides.
See,
that was,
that was crazy that he did that.
Whoa,
okay.
One,
you have people that are fighting and
whoever side you're on,
whether you're the side that wants to
keep statue up and you want white people
to get the respect or whether you're on
the side of the things that you guys are
a bunch of racists and call yourself
white nationals all day.
You're a bunch of Nazis.
W,
whichever side it is,
I don't know which side you're on,
but as soon as someone Joe's driving a
fucking car into all those people and
you find out that guy is a Nazi or that
guy's a Nazi sympathizer or whatever,
he is a white nationalist,
you've got to go look.
This thinking is shit brained Shit brand
that you think you could just drive a
car into a group of people,
including a girl.
You killed a girl with a car.
Yeah,
it's who crosses the line into violence.
I was actual violence,
random violence and terrorism.
Jurors.
No,
no.
Look in the eye,
no interaction with them stomping on a
gas of a car.
It's one of the most cowardly acts you
could ever do.
It's a horrifically terrorist activity.
It's horrifically terrorist in the in
the way that it's like sheer terror that
this could ever happen to you,
that someone could just gun a car into a
random group of people and slam into
whoever didn't get out of the way and
they think that think that that would be
the thing to do against your people from
your own country,
just over ideology and and I.
Yeah,
that's unbelievable.
Whether or not you should take down a
statue of a guy who was the commanding
general in the losing army of a civil
war and you've got that in front of a
courthouse.
This is a little weird,
right?
We should have this discussion.
We should at least have this problem is
people aren't allowing discussions.
You get labeled racist,
sexist,
homophobic,
immediately or the opposite.
You get labeled a Nazi.
If you even think like from a historical
point of view like,
Hey,
we should respect that this statue is a
part of our culture and our history.
We don't embrace the ideals of the
confederate army.
We're not trying to bring back slavery.
We're not racist.
We just think that there's a unique and
interesting history of the south is as
unfortunate as it is.
It's all connected to slavery.
You know,
this,
this is not entirely with this guy
represents to us.
Like if that's the argument you're
making,
okay,
well then we should probably have some
sort of a confederate army museum.
You know,
where people can go and just observe
like the strangeness of it all because
it is strange whether or not you are on
the north and south.
It's strange that in 18,
65 people were shooting each other and
the only difference was like they were
cross align the Mason Dixon brothers
shooting your other crazy and that just
happened,
right?
Just a couple of hundred years ago.
Yeah,
we lost 800,000
people and only three percent of people
on slaves in the south.
So think about how many casualties were
like what the fuck.
The whole thing is in the immigrants in
the north just right off the boat.
Italy,
Ireland,
just grab a gun and go die.
Fuck man.
Just stop and think about how insane
that is and there should be some way
that we addressed this in,
in these areas.
I don't think it's a statue of Robert e
Dot Lee in front of some important
federal building or state building.
I think you should take all that stuff
and bring it someplace where you have
like a museum or a,
you know,
an area where you have,
where people can go and you have experts
that give tours this unexplained.
Put it all in context.
Explain who this guy was.
You know,
have like a tour that people do.
That's an allison idea.
Massively educational and it doesn't,
you know,
look,
nobody today was a part of the fucking
confederate army.
Okay?
If you're,
if you're a 30 year old guy today,
you are not a part of that.
Okay?
You're a human being that lives in
America.
You're not responsible for the sins of
your ancestors,
nor are you obligated to continue the
same ridiculous ideas that maybe you
were raised with or other people were
raised with two,
it's,
it's not smart.
We're supposed to be all in this
together.
If we all got attacked by whether it's
some invading army or fucking aliens
from outer space,
I mean that was like a famous Ronald
Reagan quote about how quickly we would
forget about our differences between us
and Russia if we were attacked by an
alien force from outside of this planet.
So true.
And it's not even just the concept of
reminiscing is new.
Like I do a song a summer of 18,
69 just to put in perspective how good
we have it now and we should be
celebrating every day.
Like Holy Shit,
you go into any drugstore.
This could've killed kings.
It's a dollar.
But like we just myself included,
I can't do that.
I just think relatively to what I've
seen in my life.
But like if you think about the summer
of 18,
69,
like people are dying of like Spanish
flu and shit like crazy.
So 100 mile ride to get butter.
Oh yeah.
I mean and that's like modern times,
you know?
I mean think about back when.
The only reason why we're here is
because people had to breed from the
time we weren't people that had to keep
from the time we were,
some sort of,
that's if you believe in all that
liberal bullshit,
but evolution,
which is mostly just a plot concocted by
the Jew.
Um,
but if you,
if you do pay attention to evolution,
we came from some sort of a lower
hominid and we evolved over time.
We kept improving natural selection and
all sorts of different factors and
mutations.
We improved and became what we are
today.
Well,
that means we had,
uh,
we had,
we,
we bred back when we were almost like
fish people,
right?
We kept going through this whole thing,
what we are today.
The only reason why anybody ever got
better than those people that had to
walk 10 miles for butter because they
were like,
fuck walking 10 miles for butter.
We've got to figure this out better.
And so no one's ever happy.
No one's ever happy with the current
state of affairs because like,
why am I still walking?
Where's my fucking flying car?
Where's my,
a tele porter?
What I can't go to Mars right now,
we're going to go to Mars right
now and that's the gene that passed.
I got,
I was trying to explain to some buddies
in the UK because I do stamp their lot.
I'm like,
Americans are a little fucking crazy
because we were the dudes who agreed to
come here,
you know,
like if you're going to do it genetic
just cut and it's like,
okay,
you're probably going to die,
but there's golden pussy.
Well it's like one out of 200 people's
like,
all right,
and then they settled in America.
Those guys need a hug.
They're insane.
And then that that's settled America and
then that's why some of us are just so
wacky.
Like people weren't even drinking water.
They're just hammered all the time
trying to make big decisions about
slavery.
It just sounds terrible,
man.
So hard.
And that's the other thing when it comes
to like racism.
Racism is horrible.
It's horrible today,
right?
But I think it's better than it.
I saw a post by killer Mike or thinks
very cool dude.
I want to have him on eventually.
I liked that guy,
seems like he's fun and he,
uh,
he had a post on his instagram about
saying America is exactly the same and
it was essentially saying you should be
armed.
He was saying anybody tells you you
shouldn't be armed and you know,
and be trained in how to use a firearm
is a crazy,
some sort of an agent of the state.
I was like,
Whoa,
killer.
Mike's going deep,
but I'm onboard.
Yeah.
Well,
but I think it is different.
I do think it is different from 1963.
I really do.
I really think it's a lot better than it
was in the sixties.
I think it still sucks in some spots
though.
And I think emotional,
like events like this,
as horrific as they are,
they're good for a lot of people that
live in places outside of their.
Well,
they didn't know,
you know,
you get caught in the pattern of
whatever your environment is and if
you're in an environment of stagnant,
ancient racism that goes back to the
slave days and goes back to pre civil
war and then it's like the same area at
the new ideas are slowly making their
way in because it's not like a lot of
influx of new people moving into these
places either.
Right.
As people having kids and the kids may
be learning a little bit at school and
you know,
it's a slow process of getting out the
shitty ideas.
It's like you're a bit about the Middle
East or the townies of the world.
It's so true.
It's like just the people that don't
weave and then.
Well it's Iraq and specific because Iraq
is Sumir,
which is where the oldest known
civilization is what's so fucked over
there that they really are like the
townies of the world and,
and like tribalism.
Like you go to UK and it's Catholic
Protestant and they don't give a shit
about.
Right.
They don't have the same history as us
and they're like,
I heard a great Irish joke.
There was a,
are you Catholic or Protestant guy goes,
I'm atheist,
and the other guy goes,
which one don't you believe in?
Where it's like are you answered them
and like you can just split it up based
on counties in England and here it's
skin and yeah dude,
when I was in Ireland in Northern
Ireland as well,
I went to Belfast once and there was a
bunch of people that were there that
were there,
you know,
the guy guys were in their late forties
and fifties.
They were telling me about back in the
day with the bombings with the IRA and
they were explaining to me some horrific
things that were done to people there.
I mean the,
these are Irish people going after other
Irish people.
Right.
And the cop cars there are fully armored
like war vehicles.
Like I've never seen anything like it
and all the places that have been.
I've never seen anything like it where
the cop cars are covered with steel
plates,
like Steel Mesh on the front steel
plates and battering rams.
I was like,
okay,
what the fuck is this?
That God's bomb proof.
I was like,
what?
It can get a lot worse,
man.
This is.
This is Northern Ireland and I'm talking
about shit.
I want to say like 2006,
something like that.
Somewhere around.
Then I was there and I was like,
Holy Shit,
you're Dan Carlin was talking about
1968.
There was like 40,000
bombings.
Like something that I had to look up.
I probably got that wrong,
but it was like the weatherman man and
all these like homegrown,
like chicken get jad.
There used to be a machine guns on the
White House.
Tooth Shit can get bad.
It's only been really good for like a
short amount of time.
That's why I value it so much.
Yeah,
but it's hard for us to have a
perspective of how bad it used to be.
You know,
if you ever seen that section of France,
that's France,
that's how you know Moroccan,
but in France if I said fronts,
I'd be an asshole.
It's weird.
So a tricky little fucking road to
navigate,
but Lido is the same way.
Have you seen that area where it's a.
it's like essentially no man's land.
You can't go into it because there's so
much unexploded ordinance that literally
there's so much toxic shit from these
bombs that is an area the size of Paris
that you can't go to.
That's a monumental like fucking fenced
off.
You can't go in there and they keep
pulling shit out of there and they're
like,
people collect them,
you know they have like a rescue them.
I mean Chai and fucking bullets and
missiles and shit.
That was recent.
Same with the eastern front and Russia,
like the ghost of the Asta Front,
that hardcore history series,
like just the bone fields where you like
things.
It's right out of a pink floyd video
where you're like,
alright,
so I have a problem with pronouns,
but it's like I'll fucking fight to the
death for this.
If you were a really smooth transition,
transgender persons,
absolutely no issue because no one can
tell.
Feel like Thai people.
You slide right in.
Nobody gives a shit slip in comes an
issue when it's not obvious.
Yeah.
It's like the valley,
the [inaudible] valley with robot faces.
Yeah.
What is that called?
Uncanny valley.
Where if it's like close,
but a little off.
Yeah,
a little like something's wrong here.
Yeah.
It's not.
No,
I'm ashes.
Ashes.
Simulation.
Like when my piano teacher got a sex
change,
like no one really cared as long as he's
still
matched that,
like the demo,
like,
like in the bills and shit like that,
you know,
it's a shit.
No one cares.
So highly publicized case.
Well the thing is why should you care?
Like do whatever you want to do,
but also,
you know,
like don't,
don't swing too hard the other direction
either.
Exactly.
It's gotta be,
it's got to be in the middle.
It's got to be like you.
You can't be a,
you don't get special treatment.
Last.
Yeah.
Well it sounded like that.
Like you don't,
we don't pull up.
Pretend you're amazing and beautiful and
incredible and a hero and you know,
such a hero and so brave like,
okay,
we should,
we should respect your choice and we
should.
You should live in a world where you
don't have to worry about people getting
upset.
That's the real problem.
The real problem is not that.
It's this amazing thing to do the real
problem as it should be able to be a 100
percent free choice that no one cares
about and no one should fuck with you
because you do it like no one should
hate you because of your choice.
The real problem is that people hate
them because their choice and then
because of that,
you want to say,
I am not like those people.
I think you're the most special unicorns
ever existed in the world and you're
amazing and you're my hero.
My hero is near that house.
Okay,
okay.
Maybe it's just 10 people are operating
from fear to where it's like they are
starting to say like a six year old can
choose their gender and then and then
have hormones that don't go through
puberty and that's when.
And that's when I think back to all
those idiots that I would always
disagree with where it's like stay away
from my kids.
Gay Guy Might,
good guys,
don't give a fuck about your kids.
But then when,
when you think like,
oh my God,
the state could enforce my six year old
a sex change.
You can't do that.
They don't do that.
It has to be the parents,
right?
The parents have to bring the kids
somewhere,
but it's the question is when is it old
enough?
Like is it okay when you're 18,
man,
I don't think you should.
I the fucking frontal cortex doesn't
even get fully formed until you're 25.
Right.
So like what are you doing?
Making big choices?
Like if I had to go back and think about
like some super important choices that I
could have made when I was 18 and
whether or not I've been rational,
I was essentially a monkey with a
language.
Like I thought like a monkey.
I act like a monkey.
There's no way I should have been ever
respond.
Especially something that could affect
you for the rest of your life.
Like the idea of when you're 18,
you can get a tattoo like Jesus Christ.
This is like sterilizing and also like
an industry can pop up.
Like my parents felt that way about
circumcision I imagine like,
like they're like,
yeah,
you guys can be circumcised and you turn
18 so you can decide on your own.
That's how it should be.
Yeah.
It shouldn't even be.
You know,
like you should be able to do whatever
you want to do when you can decide that
cutting off your wayne part of your rain
and you lose a lot of Dick's this way.
Folks.
Okay.
People don't wanna admit it,
but there's a lot of infections.
People lose their dicks every year.
Babies lose their dicks because of this.
This is a fact.
It's not a lot in terms of the actual
numbers of people that are getting
circumcised,
but it's a handful like you want to take
that chance.
Yeah.
Risk reward on that fuck all the time
about propaganda.
Saying that like,
you know you're always going to have
infections
and shit.
They were just trying to get an extra
500 bucks a clip.
How many babies do you think lose their
penis every year from infection due to
circumstances?
I say five in America.
I say five.
What'd he say?
Lose their Dick.
Because Dick had infected from clipping.
Yeah.
I'm going to say 11.
11,
11.
Okay.
Full digital.
Jim's going to pull.
Well,
any parts,
even partial loss.
Cut off the tip of your Dick that
sometimes that's just as fucked.
Going to reconstruct the tip of your
Dick.
Yeah.
I feel like my winter is like,
you know,
I got like a arm to take your nose and
they put it on the tip of your Dick and
they give you a when you.
Likewise,
I my notes,
my Dick is sniffling,
the kid can't even make a fucking choice
for himself.
I know it's happened before and one kid
lost his penis in a circumcision
accident and so they tried to transition
him to be in a woman and then he was
suicidal and they turned it back into a
man that he wound up killing himself.
It turns out that's not all societal.
It was a famous case is,
uh,
I forget the name of the boy who,
I've read that book and I forgot though.
Yeah,
I forgot to what,
which book was that?
I can't remember.
It was like a kid named Gary or one and
200.
One into whoa.
I have what it was,
were real bad.
Wound infections serious is what it
says.
One and $200.
Okay.
But how many of them lose their dicks?
I don't.
Didn't do studies on.
I saw a study once that said that more
teenagers than ever are engaging in anal
sex.
And I thought about that.
I was like,
who the fuck is doing that science?
Like what?
Scientists sitting around like,
hmm,
what should I study?
Global warming asteroidal impacts.
Know How many of these kids are,
but fucking I need to get those buttfuck
numbers.
I needed to get the numbers and he's
going to be honest.
It's like a.
it's like a trump poll and the election,
right?
It's true.
It's like,
who's going to be like,
yeah,
I haven't bought fucking blood fucking
favorite thing.
Well,
I think porn changed the game for all
that shit.
Like no one was.
It did for sure know.
Everyone's pretty high level going into
going into it now.
Yeah.
It's a total different experience.
It's too many people to watch them.
Too many people.
Fuck now.
It's not the same experience.
It's freaking people out.
It is.
I had a similar experience to you with
the.
With the play in the woods.
We call it spank mountain.
Everybody did do.
That's where they were.
Everybody found them in the woods,
man.
Either that or you found them in like
your friend's Dad's garage.
It looks magazines tucked in the corner
and some fucking fire hazard situation.
Dude,
my buddy once traded a playboy for a gun
magazine saying there was more nudes in
it and I did it and I like looked
through every fucking page and he was
just waves.
I'm like,
are you sure?
Like I was that naive.
Oh,
that's so funny.
Yeah,
because it's like they couldn't exit the
browser so they would have to like
physically put it in their heads when
they,
when they were disgusted at what they
whacked do.
When I was 20,
one of my friends found a got a hold of
one of those videos of women having sex
with animals.
It was like a barnyard betty or
something like that.
And it was a vhs tapes,
real scratchy,
fucked up copy of a copy of a copy.
Vhs.
Shame dripping with Shay.
So weird man.
So weird.
I remember all of us,
you know,
just becoming men,
20 years old,
sitting there watching it over.
I think it was someone's dad,
someone's parents house watching this
fucking video going,
what are we even seen here?
It was crazy.
My brother mislabeled,
Debbie does Dallas robocop and I was
like robocop and I just watched people
fuck for like an hour and I was like,
what the like,
it was so intense.
I still remember those feelings of being
like,
it wasn't like a rousell.
It was like arousal plus fear plus just
confusion.
Fusion.
Yeah.
Coming out of a winner.
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
Also like you never really seen people
fuck before.
It's just like whoa.
That's how they do it.
Like watch it,
go in and watch them kiss is a flop and
Ooh,
this is crazy.
And that was before fake tits.
Right.
A lot of women didn't have.
They had natural breast back then.
Yeah.
And that Bush to Bush,
that asshole hair as well.
Chaos down there.
That's why everything's a balance in
order,
man.
Well it was.
As soon as people started looking at
porn,
they started,
oh,
we could fix this and clean this up,
need to hacked this off,
put this over there,
and we need to make these bigger gear.
That efficiency guy.
I was like,
God God,
it's pretty good.
The tits bigger,
going to clean that up.
We're going to sell some product.
Yeah.
We brought in a cleaner.
A guy comes in like a Alec Baldwin in
Glengarry Glen Ross.
Who's that good coffee trim trim?
Yeah.
They changed the whole game.
The dead kids today.
I bet they have way more sex too with
like tinder and all those things.
All those ways they can interact with
each other like dating apps and shit.
See,
I want to know or maybe they're bored of
it.
Like it's so easy that they can't.
I think they're fucking up a storm
really.
But is it like apathetic?
Like they didn't earn it?
It's like a trust fund versus burning
it.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
It's not like us.
Like we had to go hunt for it.
Hunt.
Yeah.
To get up early,
you know,
you gotta make your coffee by the
firelight.
I was a paper boy,
man.
I was.
I was getting.
I was saving money,
buying stocks,
snowing today.
These kids just swipe right and fuck
that said there is no stage show up
places man.
And this cure for almost every disease
now.
It's also an issue,
you know,
didn't even have to worry about warts
anymore,
just get shot up.
But that vaccine does that work?
It doesn't have fuck girls up though.
I think it's bad for girls.
The vaccine,
the vaccine really,
but I guess it's probably like the
circumcision thing.
It's like 100 to 100.
Probably a similar number.
Nothing's perfect man.
That's a problem.
It's all.
It's okay as an order man.
Exactly.
Chaos and order and there's no water.
It's all chaos.
There's order for moments.
There's attended or.
Yeah.
It's only in like bleep brief little
areas.
Brief little patches of time and small
Yeah.
It's like the joker and Batman.
Like the joker's,
like the progressive where it's eye
exams era and he's like,
you're fucking confusing.
May you know.
It's like order and chaos.
Not Big Batman Fan.
You don't back down.
Ben Affleck became Batman.
I've never watched that one.
I've always hated that guy.
I don't hate the guy.
I don't know.
It's a strong word,
but I've always instinctively not liked
him.
He seems like the type of guy that would
work out and then like pretend you
worked out harder than he did and I'm
talking about.
Yeah,
I know that guy and that guy,
like we worked out fucking hard today.
Like did you really?
Is that guy did 10 shrugs?
I did a farmer's walk or twenties.
No disrespect to him.
He's a great actor.
He's been awesome.
A lot of movies.
I liked the guy,
but as Batman and like you just had
Christian Bale who looked like a real
batman comes jacked.
Shredded.
I believed him.
I believe he was out there fighting
crime,
I think.
I think good will hunting was so good.
It made me not like him.
I don't.
I can't explain it.
He was something about me I don't like.
It's got to be something about me.
He established that he was really good
in that recent movie.
What's that?
Recently the girl?
No,
no,
not that one.
Where the girl was a murderer.
What the fucks are called gone girl gone
girl.
Ooh.
He was good and that it's a great movie.
He was.
What'd you find out?
He did a nap in Batman.
I brought this up to you as it's like a
joke or as he's showing his abs in the
movies,
he's directing your CGI abs.
Oh,
that didn't work out.
How can you tell?
Did you see that?
You can see the lines here.
You don't see them here.
These are side by side.
See anything in the right hand side.
Not Try it.
I'll get it in motion here.
Yeah.
Now,
side by side.
He's got it.
Well,
you can see over a six bag here.
This show them again at the beginning
to,
here's Ben Affleck without CGI abs.
Let's see.
I'm not saying shit.
Well,
you just.
It's a quick.
It's a really quick cut.
It's a.
it's a defined six pack.
This seems like Hayton.
Here's what the problem with this is.
In one view,
you're not going to have abs because the
guy's core wasn't engaged in the other
view.
The guy's doing a chin up and its core
is engaged.
You fucking nerds don't even know what
apps are,
so shut out.
Unless you're willing to earn those abs,
engage the core.
No more sugar.
I don't.
I he looked thin enough and fit enough
that I could imagine him having that six
pack.
I don't think it's CGI,
but good for him.
If it is,
people love to be hating it.
Heda.
Well,
it's ever since 300 men ever been since.
Everybody's like Joe that Gerard guys,
fucking Jack.
He was the most Jack Guy that ever
lived.
He's like a fucking.
Just like Frank Zane,
when he was competing in the Arnold
Classic Right Walker,
like fight club member fight club like
that was really ripped.
Well that was Brad Pitt was super ripped
back then,
but that was 100 percent real.
Like he wasn't.
There was no cgi and back then they
weren't that shit.
I don't think they could do that back
then.
Could they?
How long ago was fight club?
90 nine ish.
Yeah.
They couldn't really do see John bodies
like.
Oh,
so Butler was CGI apps?
Yes.
Interesting brush to a little bit like.
Yeah,
they just painted them.
They basically painted the shit out of
their whole body.
I'd go with that though if given the
option,
if someone's like,
we got a pink guy.
I'm like,
yeah,
the movie though,
I mean kind of demanded it because the
movie was just fantastic visual
masterpiece where I don't think you
would have been thrown off of people at
regular bodies,
like I 100 percent support it in that
movie because like xerxes was like 10
feet tall member like the,
the Persian king and then all the other
people,
like everyone was totally jacked.
It was perfect because it was like very
much like one of those um,
illustrated books like a comic strip or
high end graphic novel come to life.
It was perfect.
I thought it was great.
Yeah.
Because if everyone looked normal,
it would just be like sad.
300 guys dying.
Even if they were in shape,
if they looked like real people that are
in shape,
you know,
some people have different body types.
Some people you don't see them.
Even if they're like fader,
you don't see him with abs even though
he's like a big power guy.
There's,
that's like,
that's the reality of humans.
There's a bunch of different kinds of
body types triggered.
There was like archetypal.
They wanted to make these like comic
beautifully.
Perfect man.
They nailed it.
They did not make these movies the shit
he never saw.
The second one maybe there once Gerard's
dead.
I'm like,
why am I watching this?
The rise of the.
Yeah.
No,
that's.
You got to go with your ride.
You can't fucking.
Maybe you have a prequel bitch.
Don't make a,
you know,
before they got the last Saturday.
I mean,
could you have like a bunch of
adventures this guy had before he got
killed?
Yes.
You had a child that just fighting that
cat and the fucking cave.
Yeah.
And once he gets cocky and he wants too
much money,
you go with him as a teenager.
You got a new guy?
Yeah.
Assembly.
Get some young dude.
Some young boy band type care.
But that has to be the end.
The end.
Yeah.
Going past that.
It's just justin bieber stars in it.
He's 20 years old.
He can get in there to give them some
fucking fake abs.
Get the demo in there and how much pussy
Justin bieber would get if they did
that,
like it would be unmanageable.
He already is probably limited,
whereas this Jimmy simulation of what
that would looked like with the 300 guys
versus $20,000.
So this is.
So this really did happen.
There really was 300 guys.
A lot of hate crimes happening right
there.
300 guys.
And how many thousand version?
20,000.
20,000
Persians holders.
Well that's not right.
It doesn't look right.
That doesn't move guys.
Oh my God.
It's so insane.
That's why they called him at mortals.
Right?
Because they just kept coming back
there.
So many of them.
You would have to be so good to beat all
their asses.
They're probably beating their own
assets,
waiting to get in on you.
You.
This is blowing my mind.
This is stable.
That's a phish concert.
Smells just as bad,
but it kind.
But over there I didn't do it.
Oh,
look at that.
So insane.
Carlin did a good job with that one.
The king of kings series.
Yeah.
Dan Carlin does a great job with
everything,
but this is really is insane that this
happened,
that they really did try to hold off all
these people.
Holy Fuck.
What a sea of humans,
and it's not fair because they're fresh.
By the time they get to you,
you're.
You're already beat down.
You fought killed seven dudes already,
but now,
yeah.
Now you have high ground just with
bodies.
Yay.
A little bit about this in your life.
This is just computer simulations.
Yeah.
Nobody knows.
Nobody has an idea.
See,
that's how naive I am.
I'm literally just buying it like I'm
like,
Oh shit.
This is exactly it.
I had this super stoner
idea.
Once that one day they would come out
with a computer that is so powerful that
it calculates the position.
This would have to be dependent upon a
bunch of other technologies that are
new,
like specifically the ability to monitor
every single thing on earth in high
definition and then put all that
information to some crazy supercomputer
so you look at every object that is in
every position,
wherever it is and somehow or another
they could figure out how everything got
there and through some super powerful ai
that's hasn't even been invented yet.
They would literally be able to recreate
every single moment that happened that
led to that happening right there.
Like you get the math and just go
backwards.
Either.
We realized at one point,
this is a super stoner idea that I don't
think is real.
Folks.
You're so fucking stupid.
You understand how time works.
That's not what I mean,
but my.
This is my super stoner idea was that
they would figure it out.
Computers that are so impossibly
powerful and they can calculate and
extrapolate and do this crazy sort of
some sort of algorithm that figures out
exactly how everything got to wherever
it is and that you could recreate in
some sort of visual form everything
that's ever happened ever.
I think that's possible.
Theoretically,
we're both so high.
We shouldn't be talking about this
publicly.
We totally possible,
but we'll never get there if we keep
hiring 50 slash 50 gender.
I'm just kidding.
Oh my God.
You're a misogynist.
I'm only kidding.
I saw a lot of people that said that guy
was a misogynist.
That's.
That's like calling everybody in Nazi.
He can't do that.
You've got to be careful because then
you see a real Nazi and it's a,
it's a different thing.
It's like,
um,
the issue that I have with 10,
nine rounds in mma sometimes at 10,
nine round dude,
get the fuck beat out of them and other
times a 10,
nine round and it could be either one,
I can't have,
it's not the same thing.
You gotta you gotTa have a new name for
it and that's sort of how I feel.
Terrible explanation,
terrible comparison rather.
But that's what I think about people
calling someone a massage and it's like
a massage just to someone who hates
women.
If someone writes a page and a half of
different ideas of how you can encourage
women to get into tech and so they will
be more represented that you know,
like make it more interesting for them
or ways to get them in.
That's not a misogynist.
It's the opposite of a misogynist.
I mean,
just because someone doesn't tow the
current lefty liberal line,
it doesn't mean that you're a
misogynist.
You gotta think about what this is
saying.
No one's saying women can't do
something.
No one's saying women are less
qualified.
What he's saying is that women are more
inclined to choose different things.
That's it,
and this is supported by science and it
doesn't mean you hate women.
If you think that the reason why there's
whatever the percentage is 10 percent or
15 percent or 20 percent of women in
tech,
if that's,
if that's that way,
just because 20 percent of the women who
decide to go into college and decided to
pursue a career are interested in it.
If that's.
If it's any other reason we need to
examine it,
but if it's that reason,
then we should just kind of accept it
for what it is and try to make it easier
for those women that worked there.
I don't know how the fuck to do that.
I don't work in an office,
but I would imagine there's got to be
ways,
you know,
I would imagine just treat people with
respect,
you know,
figuring out a way to make that a
priority in your office or a part of
your business or the culture of your
community.
Yeah.
Just focus on the individual,
not the group.
Yeah.
You can't.
All girls and all boys that those
things.
It's like all white people.
That does not end well.
It doesn't end well.
It's not a good way to differentiate
whether you like someone to.
Not if it's all girl or all boy or all
white or all black or all anything.
You got to be open to possibilities.
Especially when you're not saying like,
you know,
I need a fucking.
A large white power lifter.
Well you got to go to Iceland,
you know,
gay stuff with them.
Iceland dudes know that's not being
discriminatory.
It's like you've got very specific
needs.
Oh yeah.
Those dudes.
You got to go to the north.
I needed Norwegian.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You got to go to Norway.
Rico guy.
Yeah.
You got to need.
You need one of those dudes that works
at Didgeridoo.
Oh,
you got to go to Australia.
Have you read a sports gene by
abstained?
No.
Habit.
Haven't read that.
But there's,
there's like when it comes to sports,
it's so obvious.
Yeah.
Where it's like there's one area of
Kenya where like all the winners of
every marathon come from,
but on the individual basis,
it doesn't mean anything.
You know,
like Cameron hanes would beat 99 point
nine,
nine percent of black people in long
distance running,
but the that you'd have to get really
long.
You can see those little skinny African
dudes that when marathons.
Those guys are beasts,
you cannot fuck with those guys when it
comes to running a marathon.
Those skinny dudes like that is the
build for marathons and Cam's never
going to beat those guys,
but you put them on a mountain where
they got to go up like 9,000
feet of elevation and it's a three day
run.
He leaves all those motherfuckers in the
dirt because it's a different built.
Like his build is a muscle build to the
keys.
A built guy who does endurance sports
and that's like a lot of the mountain
runners,
like a lot of the people that do those
crazy,
like the bigfoot 200.
There's a massive amount of travel and
elevation up and down.
You have to be strong.
It's not like it's not just flat ground
and if you're like a really good flat
ground runner,
it's a totally different build.
Their real skinny and it's for them it's
just about efficiency in motion and just
mad cardio.
Yeah.
It's also like a oxygen consumption.
Like that's why warm,
wet air wide nostrils you crush,
but like if you're in,
you know where he's racing with dry cold
air,
you need a lot more surface area.
That's how you have these tight noses
and saying something like that.
Someone say,
oh,
roses you like,
now that's just a fact.
You know?
It's just,
is it racist to the black guys have big
dicks.
I can't be racist if it's good.
Right?
Isn't that the question?
That has been a question that has been.
Is it a racial stereotype?
Maybe.
Maybe it's triggering to guys who have
regular sized dicks that's black,
that's who suffer with girls are psyched
to like finally get me a black one,
whoo.
Can't wait for this ride.
And then it's like you take that goofy
ride at Disney.
It's like,
Oh God,
you know,
you have kids.
Take them to Disney.
It like a one roller coaster,
like goofy's really cool,
like you're ready for that fucking
California screaming when you go upside
down and it doesn't happen.
Yeah.
It just hurts.
Like it's like an Asian with a hammer or
it's like,
oh,
this is a really good personality.
Oh my God.
He is a monster in his pants.
Like he's just constantly breaking
stereotypes in a good way.
Know.
It's like the opposite for me with
basketball first pick suck.
It's like big man.
I'm like,
don't do it.
No,
it's a bad call.
Just don't do constant let down,
but when you got to like the five to
Muggsy bogues guy,
it's like he's the greatest and I'm just
a let down.
Yeah,
it's,
you know,
there's a bunch of people that are going
to be better at things in you,
whether it's better at math or it's
better at music or it's better at
whatever the fuck it is and there's
going to be a bunch of people have all
sorts of genders that are better than
you at it and all sorts of ethnicities
and all.
They come from all sorts of different
parts of the planet and it's just,
it's not fair.
There's no fair involved.
No.
Fair.
It's not,
it's.
I know it sucks.
I know it feels weird,
but there's no fair involved in European
Jews winning more Nobel prizes than
anybody.
There's no fear involved in that is like
what are they doing?
Like how fucking smarter than like
what's going on here?
Like this is a crazy group of smart
people.
Yeah.
Crazy smart.
Also culture,
you know,
that's like black redneck,
white liberals when my favorite books by
Thomas Soul and like culture is
everything,
you know,
and a lot of it has to do with whether
or not you heard it animals or,
or had a farm and that's the size of
government you want or it's like it's
the same with like certain Chinese
people can count so well and they're so
good at math because they just,
they,
it's,
it's one,
two,
three,
four,
five and then 10,
one,
10,
two,
three.
So they never had 13,
14,
15.
That set us back a and that like
starts snowballing.
Same with like rice farming.
It's all about efficiency because it's
year round and you have like a little
amount of land and then like,
so that makes you a little more
efficient as a culture and that's not
racial.
It just means like you guys value
different shit.
Yeah,
I mean you gotta wonder how much of what
a person is in 2017.
How much of it has to do with all sorts
of factors and influences that are
completely out of your control and if,
if a lot of it,
I'm,
I'm inclined to believe it's most,
almost all of it has to do with things
that are out of your control.
Like why would you think that we'd be a
good idea to be aligned with a group of
one people that have one thing in
common,
like you're white or you're black or
whatever the fuck you are.
It's.
It isn't.
It's a holdover from ancient times.
When we were tribal and we were worried
about being invaded and everybody's
thinking,
well,
there they are.
Invading the art.
Taken away our culture,
taken away our history.
Like,
just fucking relax.
All right.
No one's taken away.
Shit,
you can't take away history,
first of all,
it's not like people are going to forget
and second of all,
like you're not here for very long,
man.
This is a short time.
You're wasting your time thinking about
some stupid shit you if you are fucking
super lucky.
You got a hundred years on this rock,
100.
And we're also externalizing pride.
Yeah.
Where it's like,
oh,
I need trump to say this or I feel shame
or pride.
It's like it should stem from your own
accomplishments and yourself,
you know,
like pride,
like what do you have pride in?
You know what I'm saying?
Happy.
You did something difficult.
You.
That's probably where it ends.
You know,
she'd be happy that you're a good person
and uh,
you know,
you should be happy that uh,
you,
you have a lot of friends and that you
enjoy each other's company and you can
make them happy and they can make you
happy and that you enjoy seeing them.
You should be happy about
accomplishments and you know,
good interactions that you successfully
navigated through with people that maybe
could have gone badly.
You know,
those are always great.
It's always good feelings when clear the
air with somebody and you give a big hug
at the end of it and everybody feels
better because those are things to be
happy about.
But people are happy about stupid shit.
You're happy about what you both like
swastikas.
So as fuck.
How about those dudes showed up with
guns.
They showed up with guns like full,
full on open carry walking the street
with military outfits on flak jackets,
machine guns showing up.
What while they're taking down this
fucking statue?
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's definitely a form of mental illness
where it's like you're living out of
trauma that it doesn't really apply to
your life.
Well,
there's no real war for these people
now.
This in,
in at least where they're standing.
So because there's no real war.
The,
they're bringing guns and they're
turning something.
The ramping up all the power and the
pressure of this moment.
I didn't see the,
what happened on the side of the left,
but I heard that they were doing some
horrible shit to people too.
And um,
there a lot of punching and people are
fucking beaten the shit out of each
other and there's piles on top of each
other.
The violence has escalated.
I have no idea who started it,
who,
I don't know.
I have no idea.
I have no idea if the police were at
fault.
There's a lot of people that believe
that the police should have separated
them and they did not.
They didn't do anything about it and
they allowed it to escalate and they
just stood back while it escalated.
Like they didn't have the power,
the manpower to go in and enforce some
sort of civility.
It's tragic.
It's horrible,
man.
I mean,
they might not have been prepared for
it.
They might not have had the resources.
I mean,
how many fucking people are working
there?
I mean there's how many thousands of
people showed up with torches.
Yeah.
It was like the opposite of woodstock
where it's like the worst possible.
Too many people.
And I think a lot of times people need a
purpose.
You know,
I'm friends with a lot of vets,
uh,
and like they have ptsd and all this
stuff and,
and a lot of them just want to purpose
because like idle time makes them crazy.
I think there's a lot of people right
now that don't feel any purpose,
so they're like listening to chat rooms,
whether it's isis or Nazis or hey,
we have a purpose for you.
You're more than just your like,
possessions.
And then that's when things become
horrifying.
Yeah.
And listen,
I know people get mad.
We're that.
We're talking about this.
People on both sides.
If you have a group of people and you
all show up with the same torch,
you're a bunch of fucking assholes.
Why do you have torches?
Did you get,
listen,
go to fucking ref stat ref rei to Joey
Diaz.
Go to Rei,
get a headlamp pro.
There is so much better than torches if
you're really concerned with seeing at
night.
Okay,
I love my headlamp.
Did this shit.
They have three different things.
You can make them strobes.
Sometimes.
I got a good one.
I think it's a black diamond.
I think that's the name of the company I
wear when I go hunting.
I put that fucker on my hat and it's
awesome.
I clicked that sucker and I could walk
around with no problem and the batteries
and these thing,
they're tremendous.
They last forever.
Why the fuck do you need fire?
Why you pretend like some intimidation
tactic or you want to bring us back to
the days,
but we didn't have fucking electricity
and you had to walk down the street with
a torch because they're almost
intentionally being like,
we're backwards.
It is exactly like that.
Headlamps,
whether they realize it or not,
it is fucking stupid.
Which some bulk bulk bulk would stop.
Stop.
You're in a bad pattern,
man.
You had a bad pattern.
You're not a bad person.
Don't get stuck in this.
Don't let this define you.
You're just a person in any one of us
could have got stuck in a shift pattern.
That's all it is.
That's what being a racist is.
It's not being a realist.
Stop.
There's assholes.
We have all colors and genders and
everything.
All persuasions.
There's assholes across the board and
there's also a lot of Nice people.
You just gotta figure out a way to
navigate away from the Douche bags and
don't be one of them,
and as soon as you show up
with a fucking torch,
yellen,
white pride,
you've taken off your shirt to show your
Nazi tattoo like dude,
do it.
The Nazi flag is literally a red flag.
It's the worst thing to do to your body
to show that you're a part of one of the
worst group ever.
In human history.
You're part of this.
They'd randomly discriminates against
Jews and wants to kill them and throw
them in ovens.
That's what they did.
Well,
that's all what it means,
but what it actually means,
this is you got to let that go.
You gotta.
Get the mustache go.
Let the swastika go.
You can get by without a swastika
tattoo.
You really can thrive.
You can be a happy person.
There's press my right,
my right.
I'm supposed to be from Germany right
before the war of the right to be part
of the group.
That clearly fucking sucks at
everything.
I didn't suck at first.
It's a good idea for some good early
policies.
It got out of hand.
He built the Autobahn Bro.
You got out of hand after awhile.
He started taking adderall right after
they've made the nurburgring.
Bringing those old Audi's around those
corners.
It's like once he made a fucking 50 mile
missile,
it was bad.
Just wasting time.
They should get into bowling.
They could be in a bowl and just as much
during the like us history,
confederate history is important part of
them all up.
Bowling's everything.
To me the same person,
same thing.
It's so true.
Go bow hunting.
Now it's way more fun.
You get into a hobby.
That's what I listen to your new hobbies
on the pod because like I'm the same
way.
Like I'll,
I'll teach myself like a very hard
beethoven song and that allows me to be
like disappear and have a hobby and a
purpose.
Like these like goal oriented purposes.
Like listen to you talk about like
getting into archery and like loving it.
And I'm like,
you know,
the little amounts of weight on a Arrow
and stuff,
and I'm like,
I need.
It.
Reminds me of hobbies is fascinating,
man.
All hobbies to me or the same thing in
that what you're trying to do is try and
focus on something and get better at it
and get figured out what it is that
makes this thing good.
You know?
It's the same thing.
It's like it's an extra.
I mean obviously they're not the same
activity,
but it's the same thing.
It's a focus.
It's an avenue for your mind.
And I feel like it's like cross
training.
I feel like when you get involved in
hobbies and you really get it,
as long as you manage them healthily,
we don't let them take over your life.
Getting better at a thing like chess or
Jujitsu or whatever it is,
gets you better at the entirety of your
life.
As long as you look at the entirety of
your life in balance and you don't let
it run away from you because I've let it
run away from me for a bunch of times.
I think we all have to stand up too.
Oh yeah.
Like I like just learning Spanish.
I'm trying to teach myself Spanish.
I have a whole new 10 minutes on the
gender of nouns like that.
I wouldn't have even thought of if I
only spoke English my whole life.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
That's.
Yeah.
I mean that's another totally different
take on things.
Right?
Looking at it from the point of view of
like any sort of Latin art or Latin,
Latin language and Luna was down a
woman.
Then you go through the whole thing.
It's like our language doesn't have any
gender assignment.
It all I'm nouns and then for them it's
everything.
You have to remember like what
everything is.
If it has a dick or a pussy,
I wonder if they're triggered all day,
all day,
all day.
Like everybody's like super settled as
gender classification.
What about non binary folks in Latin
countries?
They just must be spiraling.
What about gender fluid?
Like Julio,
you El Senor or a loss senorita.
Who are you to?
It's like zero President Taser.
They don't buy that shit over there now
and they don't even think about it's fun
doing it in Pasadena and shit because
it's like a lot of like,
uh,
Mexicans haven't even thought about
that.
It's just so second nature.
It's almost like having someone describe
our culture to us and being like,
Oh shit,
we put silicone and chicks fucking
boobs,
you know?
Well,
the,
but things more disturbing me for some
reason.
Yeah.
The new trend and fake butts.
I saw a girl just two days ago at the
hotel.
It looked like she had a diaper on.
It was insane.
She was walking around by the pool.
I was like,
this is the craziest fucking.
She had some dress on and some so
preposterously proportion to talks.
I was like,
listen,
you can't just do that.
Can just do that.
Like,
what are you doing here?
This is crazy.
Do you think it floats.
It definitely has to.
If it's all fat,
the ones that are doing it now,
apparently what they do is fat grafting.
That's the same word I use when I
describe welding fenders on a porsche.
You graft defender?
Yeah.
They call it,
they call it fat grafting,
so they take fat,
the lipids you like,
they take fat again,
one,
if they didn't tell you to get fat
first,
like,
listen,
just give you an excuse up,
just beef the fuck up,
eat a lot of pasta,
get get crazy.
And then they like,
Whoa,
you.
And then they took all that shit in your
ass.
Just thick in that beast up.
Woo.
And they have to,
they have to smooth it out too.
They don't want it too lumpy mail.
Make sure you do a good job.
I'd probably makes air travel better.
Like do you think that like you're
always so.
Yeah,
bounce.
for sure.
For sure.
He'd be like,
he'd be like,
everywhere you go,
you're sitting on a water balloon.
Like everywhere you go,
you're always engaging the core.
Yeah.
It'd be like one of them,
a yoga bubbles are those,
uh,
those balloon things just sit on one of
those things.
Those balls,
those exercise balls,
that's what it'd be like all day long.
You sitting on a giant yoga balloon,
like swimming.
I feel like you drown.
Like you're an acid.
Just be like a buoy buoys and just women
that drowned because they've asked,
but he's shown me some here.
Young Jamie,
what do we got here?
This is what you do.
Okay,
so the you suck it out of.
Even though the thighs,
the thighs and the upper middle back
area.
They suck it out of there and then
pumping your ass.
Give me some before.
After Sun.
Look at that.
Hold on.
Go back to that picture.
Jesus,
look at that.
I don't like ass and surgery.
I don't like those two words together.
I don't think.
I think as surgery,
if someone says that to you,
go,
oh dude,
I'm so sorry.
You've got to get surgery.
No,
no,
no.
I want to know.
It's funny,
Bro.
What you want to get as surgery?
Identify the Gigli fucking pillow out to
pump her up.
I'm just going to be honest with you and
you can never get mad at that point.
If someone cat calls you,
it's like you literally are just
throwing blood at tigers at that point.
The girl on the right.
Okay.
She didn't get crazy.
She was just a little conservative in
her approach.
It's like she almost like photoshop,
like she took a little off the sides and
put it in her butt and kind of see what
you did there,
but I have to do is crossfit.
Okay.
Oh,
but did you see that video of that girl
doing that clean and she falls and hits
her neck and she.
I'll send it to you.
It's dark dude.
She get hurt.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She got fucking heart.
She got hurt,
man.
For sure.
Guaranteed.
It's not good here.
Let me see where to find it here.
Eddie Bravo.
Send it to me today.
Uh,
but it's been all over.
it's been all over twitter.
Did it fall on her neck,
dad?
Dude,
she cleaned it and it landed like
literally on her neck.
It was horrific.
Or that's just eddie by himself.
Hold on a second.
I'm so sorry.
It's rough dude.
Yeah,
that's really rough.
Here it is.
I got it.
Alright,
let me send it to a young Jamie here.
Hold please.
To,
to,
to copy your link.
Oh No,
you can say share.
Right?
Can you do that?
That fucked up.
Hold on.
This is a really awesome part of the
show.
This is my favorite part.
It's called Joe is not really talking
very well because he's sending Jamie
assumption that he needs to see.
All right.
There we go.
I sent it to you.
I tweeted,
I sent it to your phone.
Was it like having a way out to.
I should.
Right.
So you have to put it up a yes.
Is that hurt?
No,
no,
that's not her.
I think more than one chick has done
that.
I'm sure he all emailed to you so he
could play it on the thing.
It's um,
uh,
you got it.
Okay.
It's horrible.
Man.
That sounds wicked horrifying.
Watch she,
she gets it up in the air and then she
loses control of it and drops it down
and um,
I don't know if she's doing.
Yeah,
it says crossfit.
Look at this.
Watch she gets up.
Oh Man.
Hey.
Yeah,
not good.
Not Good.
Look at this.
That girl could have died for sure.
For sure.
She could have been paralyzed.
She's okay.
Apparently I'm luckily because the bar
is larger than her,
you know,
the plates are larger than her body,
so as it falls,
the plates hit the ground and the thing
probably bounced off the ground,
probably rubber.
So she was all right,
but food,
that's not good.
Yeah.
And,
and that's,
that's the issue that a lot of people
have with know people getting really
crazy with those kinds of Olympic lifts
and things along those lines.
You've got to be real careful with that
shit,
you know,
it's um,
it can go wrong,
you know,
it's one of the things that I really
love about kettle bells,
like I've never had.
That kind of shit happened to me with
kettlebells.
Never lost one.
I'd lift pretty heavy with them,
but I've built up to it over the years
and I never go to failure.
Like when I'm doing is like it's hard
and makes you stronger,
but this like that,
it's not going to make you that kind of
strong like that kind of clean press
squat strong lesson that's a fucking
high level strong.
But boy that's so strength Pacific and
it's super dangerous.
Yeah.
And kettle bells more applicable to your
life.
Like now,
like I literally am swinging my baby,
like it's a Kettlebell and I'm like oh
wow.
That gym work really made me a better
dad.
I do Turkish getups with my kids.
Which ones at Turkish?
Getups you lied on your back.
I'm going to press them and I sit up
nice and I'll get up and I hold them up
in the air and then slowly let them
down.
It was way easier when they're babies,
bro.
It's hard now.
Yeah,
like that.
It's like,
it's like we're adding weight to the
baby.
I carry my kids around all the time too.
That's one thing I do.
I go hiking and I'll throw my kids and
my shoulders.
So it's like my nine year old's like 50
pounds,
53 pounds.
So I carry her up hills.
That's legit.
It's good.
It's a good workout.
Like I kind of have like a little
slightly wide hips which kind of like a
woman,
so like halfway.
So if you went the other way,
it'd be quick,
quick transition,
but it's still be six slash seven and
like just not good at basketball.
Big Sexy,
big sexy woman hippie.
But like with the baby though,
I'm like,
oh I can.
This is why women have these put 'em on
the hips.
I think that's why they have them and
have them check her out.
Yeah.
It's not to carry them around.
If they had a pouch,
like a kangaroo or in the hip and he
grew up right when they got pregnant.
Tucked a little kid right there.
That'd be amazing.
Yeah.
They just walk a little sideways limp
kids sitting right there.
Yeah.
Because like my wife's like chiseled now
from just holding the baby.
Oh yeah.
You get jacked.
Carrying around a weight all day.
It's like you're doing stuff like boxers
use hand weights and they're only like
two pounds,
you know?
Remember those ankle ones.
Never use those.
Yeah.
I used to use those for kicks.
We used to use those and people were
like,
Oh,
you're gonna fuck your knees up.
You know?
Because if you kick hard with ankle
weights on your fucking knees up,
so we always have,
but now that I'm older,
I'm like,
oh no,
no,
you wouldn't just do it right?
Yeah,
it's definitely make you stronger.
Callen one showed me you kicking a bag
and it was unbelievable to watch.
We're like onset of Sullivan and son.
He's like,
Dude,
look at this.
And he was just wham,
wham.
And I remember just being like,
fuck man,
that's a skill I'll never have that.
I really enjoy watching that.
That's a skill that I don't even believe
I have.
I don't believe it's real.
Like it's crazy.
It's one of those things where whenever
I go to workout I'm like,
I really know how to do this.
Like it doesn't seem like I should.
And it was like a machine gun was just
Bam,
Bam.
I'm like,
that's a 30 clip right there.
Well,
I just do it all the time,
but even even to this day,
like I still.
It's weird because I grew up doing it
and it's like.
So I kind of barely remember learning it
until we have a piano.
I'm,
I'm playing Bach and I'm like,
so your fingers just find the keys and
I'm like,
uh,
I'm just,
I'm like retarded,
you know,
and I'm playing
like the craziest songs ever written.
We made this video because Eddie Bravo
had always seen me do this and he would
tell people and they would go shut the
fuck up,
you know,
because everybody always thinks that
everybody's,
everybody's always exaggerating about
their friend who does something,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is.
And so he was always like talking to me
about,
about a martial arts kicking.
And I was like,
well there's a lot of like problems with
some of the ways some people kick and I
would explain it to him and then I would
show them on a bag and he'd be like,
what the fuck?
Like how long have you been able to do
this?
I'm like,
I've been doing this my whole life.
Like how do you know how to like,
this is crazy.
I can't believe you can do that because
muscle memory.
Well I grew up doing it,
you know,
it's,
it's just a part of how my body moves.
But because I don't really remember
learning it,
it does feel weird.
It feels,
it feels like I'm not sure I really can
do it until I do it.
And then every time I do it I go,
oh yeah,
yeah.
I'm like the shock and awe of a kick.
Oh,
it's horrible.
Like even if there's someone that is
more my speed,
if they just bust out a big kick,
I'm like,
yeah,
it's all right.
Yeah.
My wife,
she is a bitch.
Especially leg kicks man,
if you like see,
like a really good,
like tie fighter and you watch someone
kicked someone's legs.
It's so horrible.
Like the sound it makes and the power it
has.
I see that in the UFC all the time.
It's one of those still to this day,
one of the hardest because I'm like,
God dammit.
I don't think people are appreciating
how hard that is.
Like it's like that other guy's in pain
right now.
It's just kinda awesome poker face.
Like he just got ate up with that kick
and then by the time a guy does start to
show it,
you're like,
oh no,
he's done.
His legs are gone.
I've always wondered that.
Like they just don't show it right
because that.
Yeah.
Oh for sure.
The toughest man in the world.
If in women,
you know,
if you,
if somebody who was not trained got
kicked like that and like I want to feel
what it feels like in like,
you let someone like Tyron Woodley or
something that UFC welterweight champion
let him lead.
Kick you like,
Oh my God.
But how do you think can be a real lift
your leg up and you check it.
I'm like,
you would,
um,
you would try it like they're trying to
hit them,
meet their blood.
They could be trying to hit low too.
That's actually a more recently I'm a
much more used tactic is the low leg
kick where they're attacking like
literally,
like right above the ankle.
That's nasty.
And they clip right above the ankle with
your Shin and it just swells up real bad
on,
on a lot of guys.
You can't,
you don't really condition that area
like over low by the ankle,
but the thigh you can condition,
you can take a few shots and then the
other thing you do is as the shots
coming in,
you lift your leg up a little bit and
kind of turn your foot out and so the
idea is that your Shin and your thigh
take the brunt of the hit instead of
just the meat of the thigh.
Can you help bone density or is that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it helps bone density.
It actually.
What it is is as you keep having impacts
over and over again,
a bunch of things happen.
One is there's a bunch of little
microfractures that happened,
the heel up and it gets harder.
Also,
there's a calcification that happens
because there's a lot of bleeding.
Like a lot of those guys like if you
feel their shins,
they're like Jesus Christ,
like,
like a rock man,
um,
is a student pet is a bunch of those
dudes that are fighting in more time
that can kick through baseball bats.
It's super common,
like all those high level guys can most
likely kicked through a baseball bat.
It's hilarious when you watch them do it
too,
because it looks so terrifying.
That has just kicked critiquing another
animal.
Just like that's a dumb.
Yeah.
They've made their shins so fucking hard
and they kicked so hard.
They can just smash right through
things.
Like if a guy like that is kicking your
leg,
you're in a nightmare.
It's,
it's,
it's a terrible place to be.
Yeah.
I played football.
So like when you talk about brain
injury,
sometimes I'm like,
man,
am I going to end up crazy?
Because I used to take so many hits to
the head.
Yeah.
This,
I forget this gentleman's name,
but why I watched him do this.
He's warming up right there.
And here it comes.
Dude.
He just snapped that baseball bat path.
Fuck all that.
I forget that guy's name.
He's a famous,
uh,
see if he could get his name because
he's a famous.
Uh,
yeah.
Melcher milk.
How do you say his name?
Melcher men,
nor I hope I'm saying his name right,
but he's a Moitai coach.
I'm one of the seasons of the ultimate
fighter,
the early days,
but real respected a tie fighter and
coach.
There's a bunch of guys who could do
that.
It's a real common move actually with
more tie fighters.
They kicked through baseball bats.
Here's another one.
So that's,
that's a broken shinbone not for him,
for you and me.
Yeah.
This guy's going to kick through it
while he's got like a cord attached to
his leg.
Did a sports science.
Oh,
so I got like,
look at this dude.
Why in the fuck dude?
Who was that same guy?
Yeah,
so he doesn't all the time.
That guy's probably busted 100 bats.
If that guy kicks you,
it would hurt so bad.
Oh my God.
Dude.
It would have been one of the worst
things that's ever happened to you and
then everything else,
it's like your basement flooding.
It's like,
what can you do when you don't have a
foot to stand?
Well,
you can't punch either you like your
punches or they become like these
windmill punches.
You can't pivot off your foot.
You know you can't place weight on it.
You're in agony.
It's like ready to give out and they
don't show it.
Yeah,
well a lot of them don't.
Yeah.
A lot of them have an awesome poker
face.
Like it takes a while.
Cool.
It's the hardest.
Probably the hardest sport to ever
compete in.
I'd be like,
fuck,
if it's not the hardest sport to compete
in,
I'd like to know what is it's got to be.
It's one of them because strengthened
durrance mental ability.
You know,
you're basically a quarterback and a
running back and linebacker at the same
time.
The only thing that I would think might
be harder to do is those ultra marathons
when those dudes are running,
like they were talking about the big
foot 200.
When those dudes are running 200 miles
over mountains,
that might be harder to do than an mma
fight.
Like if you thought of the amount of
people that could fight an MMA fight
versus the amount of people that could
run for eight hours in a row run 200,
five miles.
How many.
Hm.
I think it's.
It's close.
Real close.
There are different things obviously
because one of them is dealing with
getting your ass kicked,
but the other one is dealing with your
own demons,
like your demons that wanting to quit
demon and the the.
How much did you prepare?
Did you prepare properly?
What about the discipline demon?
You know,
fuck off demon that tripped up the
discipline demon and you didn't get in
good enough shape to really run 205
miles and 78 hours,
which is just insane man.
Versus self versus man versus man.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
The white whale versus a war movie,
you know,
it's like your golf.
They always say he played.
I've never played golf,
but like they say,
you play yourself.
It's about.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
I mean,
you always get the shot,
right?
You get your own shot,
you set it up on the tee,
you get to whack it,
you move it around.
No one's knocking it out of the way for
you.
It's not like pool.
Not like hiding the ball on you.
Right?
Just uverse self 78 hours.
I can't fucking crazy.
That might be harder.
It might be harder than an MMA fight
because.
Yeah,
because they're resilient.
I just can't even picture being awake
that long.
Like I've been up for 40 hours and like
I'm listening to you definitely
hallucinating.
People hallucinate when they run,
when they run those races.
Yeah.
I was hearing that guy on your shelf.
I know the one about the baby and
Everest.
Oh yeah.
That was my friend Ben O'brian.
Yeah.
That was altitude sickness and a
altitude sickness and some sort of a,
a probably a stomach bug and the two of
them together and he was just tripping
balls.
He saw baby saw wolf that didn't really
exist like he was out of it.
I feel like like if people aren't
reacting to a giant baby that you see,
that would be the like,
it's like you guys don't see this giant
baby who'd feel like such a fucking
idiot.
He'd be like,
oh no,
what do I do now?
Like that hits so many levels of primal
shit,
like take care of the baby,
but also like,
what the fuck is going on with this
baby?
Oh fuck a baby just in the woods.
I imagine if you're just walking through
the woods,
you find a baby.
What do you do?
Like you're deep in the woods.
Did take the baby.
I feel like you got it right.
If you take.
Do you have to sit with the baby and go,
hello?
Anybody messing the baby's right here,
but whoever,
but if you steal the baby it's like you
piece of shit.
I was just going to the bathroom.
Took my fucking kid.
I called.
I called out where I was pants down some
crazy hood rat having a baby in the.
Taking a shit in the woods.
Baby.
Baby and wilderness.
You should take the baby,
right?
Yeah.
You should just plop you know the baby
down on the ground right next to where
he shit.
Keep an eye on them and don't shit on
him.
Yeah,
I mean there's holes and raccoons and
all the things we've been discussing,
but you're talking about shame of shit
next to a baby with no memory.
Yeah.
I'm just not a good argument.
That's for sure.
Terrible run.
Yeah.
You gotta watch those babies.
Man.
I like what you were saying,
how your wife started to get like
really like concerned about things when
she had a kid.
Yeah,
that's what,
that's normal natural thing.
That's why we get so freaked out when
someone leaves their kid in the car.
Like what?
You left a baby in the car by itself.
Oh,
you're,
you're not doing this right?
Yeah.
That's when I really get triggered.
Like if I do like child abuse stuff,
that's what I'm like.
I,
that's what I think people are
describing.
What triggered?
I literally get angry.
Oh yeah,
sure.
Child abuse stuff for sure.
Yeah.
You see somebody yanked their kid.
I saw some lady kicker kid in a video
online.
She was a baby,
like a two year old last kicked it like
hard and the kids stiffened up,
like probably got code.
It was horrible,
horrible to see campus crawling around
on the ground and she just kicked it.
Don't pull it up please.
Okay.
So you type it in like you saw use.
Um,
it's just that stuff is triggering.
Right?
Same with dogs.
Like there was this video or some
chicken,
a subway just hitting a dog and I'm
like,
you know,
Ooh,
that's just makes it like,
it triggers everything in me that
protects weakness where I'm like,
they can't protect themselves.
What about ostrich?
A punch the shit out of an Australia.
Yeah.
It's all about hockey.
They get cocky on you.
They'll start pecking.
You did he met?
Chickens will come at me,
there'll be like super scared and then
they'll start being a dick.
If you have bare feet,
they'll go for your toes.
Yeah,
I think it might be able to eat a tow.
My brother Fed it chicken,
which is a fucked up.
Do that.
That's how you get mad chickens too.
They have mad chicken disease for up
like that.
It's like upset chicken.
It's like not quite as bad and we're on
fear factor.
I got attacked by an ostrich.
Not really.
If I was like an exaggerator I would say
to attack me,
but definitely took a swing at me.
If you were a buzzfeed,
you were attacked by.
Grabbed his neck.
I was like,
bitch,
get the fuck out of here.
Like it,
it came close enough where I had to do
listen and then push it away from me,
get away from the fence and they try to
fuck you,
fuck you up.
Rather they try to get some fucking,
they don't want you there and you're
like bitch,
get the fuck out because they can like
take a person kinda right.
They're not a small animal.
And what's interesting is they have red
meat,
um,
they have ostrich burgers that you get
at fuddruckers and they're quite
delicious and they're actually very high
in protein,
like much higher in protein I think than
beef.
I think they're up there with like wild
game,
like in the neighborhood,
like maybe not.
Why not?
Maybe not like,
like wild Mousse or something like that.
But in the neighborhood,
like getting closer to that than it is
to like beef and it's a real lean but
it's weird because it's like
essentially,
again,
it's a fucking dinosaur looking at a
diet and you think like,
this is gonna be like chicken.
No,
it's not only chicken dogs red to red
meat.
It's fucking crazy old raptor.
Who Do you think real ostrich Kent.
A kangaroo.
Who Do you got money on?
Dude?
That's a good question.
The kangaroo.
Clearly,
because they'll choke you.
Kangaroos will choke you.
Plus they sit back on their tail and
they fucking punt you.
Right?
You know,
I don't think an ostrich can fuck
with that.
Ostrich is going to try to kick the
kangaroo.
The kangaroo recently pitch.
You simply can't sit back on your tail,
Bro.
It's like a guy who took like,
Ooh,
look at this.
Is there a kangaroo versus an ostrich?
This natural fight.
Is it really an EMU?
But.
Oh,
it's an email.
It's close enough to.
It is like a kangaroo.
Right?
So it's a kangaroo in an email.
I thought an email is like a peacock.
Oh Shit.
Oh Guy.
Oh,
that thing looks scary.
See,
I would have my money.
I don't know if it was bigger for sure.
Email.
Huh?
There's two of them.
Yeah,
but that's a little ass kangaroo.
It's true.
That kangaroos small.
They have big giant Kangaroos,
man.
Some dude got fucked up by a kangaroo
recently.
Well,
this is a crazy little fight here.
The email was all goofy.
He's like shucking and Jiving,
well fake moves,
trying to fake them out.
He's like,
no,
the Kangaroos,
like I'm taking this food bitch,
this is my food.
And the email was like,
oh motherfucker,
I'm taking that food.
They'll get the email is like literally
like a star wars bird doesn't even look
real like the shadiness and that they're
ready to go at it.
It looks like it would fight like
drafting like this with its neck just
like it.
Well you might be right.
It's like,
it's like scary and like precious at the
same time.
It's like hello.
It's the same posturing.
Yeah.
Not Making a move.
Come on bitch.
It's like a fancy trying to stomp their
shit technique.
The kangaroo.
I just charged this bitch.
I with this guy doesn't know what the
fuck he's doing.
I just get to move in on this.
There's three of them.
Yeah.
But if you.
I bet if you smack one of them.
The other two,
it just got a stupid thing to think of.
Is there ever.
Is there a contact?
I Dunno.
I don't think so.
Things his bitch ass fight.
Didn't they get one of those big angry
Kangaroos?
That's a little tiny baby.
Kangaroo form.
Yeah.
The end of the day.
That kangaroo got all the fucking leaves
was stupid.
Birds need to step the fuck back and
respect the superiority of the mammal.
I'm on team Malmo.
I don't give a fuck.
I think people should all be lumped in
together as one unit,
but it's US versus them.
When it comes to mammals have
breastfeeding big.
The mammary gland.
Yeah.
If you have an egg,
your kid comes out of an egg the fuck
out.
Get out of here.
You're not part of the conversation.
That's so old.
That's like driving around and some sort
of a horse buggy.
So literally they're hipsters.
Imagine if a woman,
your wife gave birth to an egg.
I sit on it.
Wait,
just sit there.
Keep that egg warm.
Yeah.
Ridiculous.
But if it was like the Pangolin yeah.
Penguins are like almost like throwing
the frog.
Like the Inbetween Bucher.
They fly.
They have to keep the baby on their
feet.
Remember that they.
They put the baby up high on there.
Otherwise,
it'll freeze if it touches the ground,
the,
the environments that they're like smart
social,
that's like nature.
Just telling you,
look dude,
your contributions are really non
valuable.
Okay.
We're barely accepting this model still
right now.
If it wasn't for the Tuxedo,
you guys are out there essentially
population control for local fish and
their food for leopard seals.
That's their position.
Just keep.
Keep making those babies and keep
holding onto those eggs.
It's a niche.
No,
and the dude that's a.
it's a weird society because the dude
has take care of the egg.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Like chick takes off,
gets a bunch of fish,
stuffs in her fat face comes back,
but it's a long ass hall and during this
long ass hauled,
the dude has to take the egg and sit in
on his feet.
Nice.
And he's got to protect it from the snow
on the ground.
The blizzard conditions.
And those are gender roles and gender.
Yeah.
Look at that man.
See that's a male holding on to the egg
and then the babies are about to be born
baby.
Like I'm out of here,
bitch.
Yeah.
Actually what that is,
or modern,
they're very modern birds.
Cute little fuckers too.
Just because I'm a man doesn't mean I
can't sit on my fucking leg.
It's just weird because they're almost
defenseless is like nature saying no,
you can't even fly,
dude.
No,
we're not going to let you can.
Well,
yeah,
when you're on the ground,
you can't move fast.
We want you like lumbering.
Barely.
You have to give birth on the ground.
The only time you can get away from
anything is when you're in the water,
but you're rarely in the water,
so stay on the ground and be vulnerable
with a walk.
It's so absurd.
If you played like a Tuba,
it's like a comedy.
Yeah.
This is not a penguin alive that I
couldn't beat in a race.
I can be drunk and I'll beat them.
I'm like,
C'mon Pussy.
Ready?
Set.
Go.
Fuck you.
They're absurd animals because they have
no,
but they do have predators though.
How come it's not just like they're not
wiped out.
Leopard seals are.
They Jack them,
but they can only eat so many.
Leopard seals are fucking huge,
man.
There's a leopard seal,
killed a photographer a few years back.
It was the first time ever is there,
which is weird because they're
apparently,
they're very intelligent too,
and they've,
they've actually brought photographers
and divers.
They brought them up,
seals till a sealer,
a penguin,
not a seal,
a penguin.
They'll kill a penguin and bring it over
to a photographer and try to like the
photographer,
like eat,
come on man,
eat.
He was hungry and if like tried to help
them and they've hung out with them for
days on end.
It's really something amazing footage of
those things.
But um,
as far as I know,
they very,
very rarely attack people and that was
the only incident that I had ever heard
of where they had killed somebody.
But it was pretty recent,
like within the last 10 years I think.
Wow.
They don't look real men.
Leopard seals.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen him?
That's one right there.
Please look at the teeth on that thing.
Look in the fucking teeth in that thing.
At that time she opened her mouth and
her head was twice as large as a grizzly
bears head.
What in the fuck,
like how come when we were kids,
we never heard about this.
Look at the size of that fucking thing.
So this is the.
This is the leopard seal that was trying
to feed the photographer,
the photographer.
What does the site,
Jamie,
I just a son imager.
It's just a series of pictures or you
can find it.
Folks.
I have faith in you,
but they're worth looking at.
These photos are amazing.
This creature doesn't look real.
Like look at the face on that thing with
the teeth.
It looks like the thing from neverending
story,
like the smiling where it's like,
hey man,
you want some fish?
And just think about the massive.
Yeah,
with a face that's twice as large as a
grizzly bears head.
What?
Just think about how fucking big grizzly
bear is,
dude.
That's twice as big.
It's like this enormous avatar demon
that lives in the water and eats
penguins.
They're amazing.
I mean,
it's just one of the most astounding and
an overlooked,
underappreciated animals in the ocean.
Yeah.
I never knew any of this until right
now.
This is a fucking mammal.
You know what I mean?
Look at that thing.
Just chill in there.
It's like smiling.
It's like,
man,
it's fucking a huge killing machine,
man.
Probably need a penguin.
I got a guy.
I mean,
when you think about seals,
what do you think of?
You Think,
oh,
have cute little fellows.
The hang out and eat some fish.
Not this motherfucker.
This is a murdering machine and it's the
biggest one,
right?
So this is a big ass giant seal that
just killed shit.
Why did they hang with the other types
of seals?
Or is there a wonder if the other seals
have like websites dedicated to shitting
on the leopard seals are slippery
privilege.
Yeah.
Privilege and prejudice.
All of it.
Leopard seal privilege is real,
Bro.
It's so real.
It's the most real thing in the world.
You know what's fucked up is like sexism
does exist.
You know,
a shit thinking does exist.
Like real hard line,
dopey,
right wing ideology does exist,
but when you pretend that ideas that
oppose you are those things that are all
the ideas that oppose your super or
outright,
and that's one of the things they've
been doing with Jordan Peterson and
recently it's crazy.
These,
um,
these are the authors of these articles
about him and the,
of Charlottesville and all these
different things.
They'd have him lump Jordan Peterson
have him lumped in,
but we're actually not charlottesville
because of the Google memo.
Um,
have him lumped in with far right.
They called them a far right.
Conservative.
It's just not true.
It's not true when it also muddies the
water.
So there's no meaning and they call them
outright like he's not all right.
He's got,
damn.
He's a professional intellectual genius.
He's absolutely a genius and a kind
person from what I've heard about.
Very kind,
very sweet guy.
I really,
I really enjoyed talking to him.
He's,
he's genuine and he has real concerns
about all these things.
And I think
very valid concerns in particular about
people wanting to enforce their ideas on
other people and make people behave a
certain way and there's a real
inclination that people have for that
they really do.
And you're seeing that with
Charlottesville mean part of the
reaction to all this stuff.
Part of the reaction to all this stuff
is realizing that this,
these,
this kind of thinking can exist,
right?
That this,
this shit that you didn't expect to see
can just pop up like that.
Like I'm almost thinking we have to see
it to know it's real.
Yeah.
Because I thought a lot of this was
gone.
Like I was fairly naive about it because
I,
you know,
I hear people overuse these words all
the time and I'm like,
no,
these people are gone.
We beat these people.
We don't even let them adopt highways,
you know?
And then you call other people Nazis
that aren't,
that if fucks the whole thing up.
That's not a Nazi,
that's a Nazi right there.
They are.
And you have to be able to identify it.
It's also extremely,
uh,
a shitty to,
to people that have been victims of
actual Nazis.
Yeah.
Where you're like,
oh,
a microbes like a microaggression at
Brown isn't my fucking grandmother and
an oven.
That's not the same thing.
In other words,
too many don't.
I mean,
the problem is that it's an indefensible
word.
You call someone a Nazi and it's
indefensible.
You put them on their back heels and
then they have to deal with that.
Well,
that's what annoyed me about the right
when I was a kid was a sinner or like
Jesus because Jesus where it's like it's
a conversation ender and that's why I
saw almost that flip where now I see the
left doing it where it's like racist.
It's like,
dude,
we're arguing about like a proton,
like what does this even mean?
It's just like a way to end a
conversation.
And I'm like,
it's starting to.
Yeah.
Starting to act like a religion where
it's,
where it's like white guilt is original
sin and then being woke is baptism and
veganism is kosher and it starting to
align up Kurt Metzger.
I do love Kurt.
Yeah.
Great Guy.
He grew up Jehovah's witness,
so you know,
he's super resistant to any like
enforced ideology and he was like,
no,
no.
I've seen this before.
You can't tell me what's right,
is wrong,
and right is left and left is right.
He's like,
I know what you're doing.
I've seen this before.
I've seen this when I was a Jehovah's
witness,
and it was like,
that's exactly what it's like.
It's like this enforcing this and in
silencing debate like there's.
There was one of the things that was
talked about in the Google memo that I
thought was fascinating was that certain
subjects are too sacred to be discussed
and that that is one of them like gender
in tech.
Apparently I don't work in tech
obviously,
but in gender in specific like any,
any women's issues,
you're not supposed to discuss them as a
man and a men's issue discussed by a
woman is like the thought of a woman
trying to steal your money or come up,
she'll sneak your divorce laws are,
you know,
we don't want anybody having any opinion
whatsoever about a side of.
They're not on that list.
It limits growth and it's the opposite
of science,
like scientists.
Science is skepticism.
The whole thing is ask why until you hit
a wall,
you know it isn't like to not address
this and people get labeled toxic and
just kicked out toxic.
A dumb one.
Toxic masculinity and by the way,
there's a lot of women that are like
evolutionary psychologists that know a
shitload more about men than even men
do,
right?
Yeah,
sure they do and you got to listen to
them if they're explaining the actual
evolutionary mechanisms that have caused
human beings to behave a certain way and
why more men are inclined to favor of
specific activities and you look at all
the different numbers and variables that
you could look at in terms of like how
many more men die on the job,
how many more men picked,
you know,
difficult job and also like this weird
thing that we're doing where we're like
trying to pretend that things are
different than they really are to sort
of support your point better.
Like that's one of the things that
people do with the gender pay gap,
right?
There was one to say,
well,
the gender pay gap shows is real
prejudice between men went,
no,
no.
It's not what it shows it all kind of
thing.
It shows that women and men choose
different jobs and and when I told a
good buddy of mine that he didn't
believe it,
he was like,
there's no way I go,
that's what the gender pay gap is.
He goes,
no,
I thought it was like men,
women and men doing the same job and the
woman makes seventy seven cents on the
dollar.
No,
no,
no.
That would be horrible.
Right?
That's not what it is.
They choose different jobs.
I look at men and women doing the same
job.
The difference is very small and when he
found that he was angry,
he was like,
are you fucking serious to me?
I got pissed.
You get sick,
you get mad because you hear the
president,
President Obama was talking about that
on television.
Surely someone must have alerted him.
Mr.
President,
this is disingenuous line of,
thank you,
Mr.
President.
This is nonsense.
It's not.
It's like they took every man and woman
and just put a line at the 50th
percentile and anyone who knows anything
about math,
that's insane.
Like there's so many factors.
Just the factor of having a child.
Oh yeah,
like so then you quit for 10 years,
you come back,
you're going to make less money.
That all goes into the pay gap thing or
if he even quit for a few months.
I mean,
you know,
whatever it is,
the time that you have to take off,
that's going to.
And then women work less frequent hours.
They work less hours.
Whether they,
they take less overtime.
It doesn't mean that they're not just as
good at a job as a man.
Is that a job?
It just means that overall they're
probably going to earn less money in
that sort of scenario.
They choose different jobs,
they work less hours.
That's just.
I'm not saying that that's the,
you know,
they don't get some sort of
discrimination.
I wouldn't want to be a chick work with
a bunch of dudes.
I wouldn't want to be that.
That's a different argument.
I think women working with.
God,
I think there'll be terrible,
especially if you're attractive,
if you're attractive women,
you've got to work with like 10
dickheads at some stupid fucking ups
office.
I bet it sucks.
I bet those guys are annoying as fuck.
They say stupid shit about you behind
your back.
You know?
I'm sure it's horrible,
but that's a different argument.
One hundred percent.
It's not.
It's not saying,
okay,
we're not saying that there's not some
discrimination.
I'm sure there is,
but that's not saying that that's
happening in tech to the point where
there's a reason why there's 10 men and
for women that's not.
That doesn't necessarily make sense and
as soon as you do that,
like what you said,
equality of outcome.
Yeah,
that's the perfect way to describe it.
because it it,
it guarantees that you're going to have
a problem and it also the biggest victim
or women that feel like they have to be
a CEO and a mom to be like normal and
it's like that's an impossible position
to put somebody in where it's like if
your instinct wants a child but you
don't want to slip at work at all,
it's like dude workings for pilots.
I,
my wife made life with her body and I'm
just like,
oh,
do the funny bone.
Here's more money.
It's like,
I agree,
but I also could see it from the point
of view from a woman who doesn't want
that new law.
Of course I'm just talking probability
just effect.
They have a womb.
Is gonna Affect Profitability,
you know?
Even if it's one percent.
Yeah.
It's like if it's one percent,
I would never tell a woman that she has
to have kids or not pursue any life that
they want.
Not at all.
Why don't think anybody should tell
anybody what to do.
I mean,
that's the whole point of all this,
but I think we should also stop
pretending that there's not some sort of
a meritocracy going on when it comes to
most corporations,
most jobs,
you know,
whatever discrimination that there is,
boy,
I really hope that gets routed out so we
can concentrate on what's important and
what's important is people finding
something they enjoy and doing it
without discrimination and doing it
without,
you know,
having to deal with too much resistance
from the people that you're doing it
with,
you know,
and that's,
that's a harmonious life,
right?
Find something you love,
find some sort of a path of least
resistance to get to it.
We can really enjoy it and participate
in it.
Hopefully with likeminded people.
Like one of the things that I've always
been really happy about the store and
about standup comedy in general is that
there,
it's a brotherhood and a sisterhood.
Like when Whitney Cummings comes around
the comedy store,
she's as much my brother or sister as
any of the other guys.
It's Andrew Santina was one of these
guys.
We're,
we're a family there.
Of course there's not a whole lot of us
is very few and if you get through and
you're funny if you're Sarah Silverman
or you know,
name that personally you're treated with
the same amount of respect that guys
are,
at least I would hope,
at least in the circles are the people
that I enjoy.
You are.
Yeah.
At least you're,
you,
I mean you were held up to the same
standards as well,
you know,
and you're also like,
like if you ask people like who's funny?
The we,
we like funny people,
you know,
like if you say like,
Hey,
did you see Sarah do said in the main
room,
Holy Shit,
the fucking crush dude.
Like people tell you in sight,
there's no sexism when it comes to that.
It's a total results based appreciations
standard.
Yeah.
It's like fighting and comedies the same
way.
The stakes are so high you,
you develop a no nonsense vibe where
it's like,
dude,
bombing sucks.
So like I can't say like I have to just
be like,
what joke is funny,
like I can't do the nonsense.
Just like with fighting,
it's like well if you commit to just
taekwondo and not do the full package of
Jujitsu and all that shit,
like you're at a disadvantage.
So it's like that all like that.
That identity can hurt you if you don't
branch out into like what works,
you know?
I don't know shit about fighting
obviously,
but I've just heard you talk about like
it just that well rounded grappling and
striking and all that shit.
Like the stakes are so high that you
can't really be nonsense.
The only other option is going to be a
specialist at such a high level that you
better than everybody else at one thing.
Like you get with this Guy Damien Maia
who just last actually two guys more
well rounded ironically,
but he's been able to beat so many world
class fighters just because he's so
amazing at Jujitsu.
It gets a hold of guys,
drags him to the ground and either
strangles them or it gets really close
to strangle them to the point where he
dominates all the exchanges.
He's done that with like,
I think you beat six or seven guys in a
row and really good guys by really
Carlos Condit,
former interim welterweight champion,
strangled them,
got them on the ground,
choked him out.
So it's like there's a few guys that can
do that,
but for the most part you've got to be
able to do everything.
And I think,
um,
if you have blind spots when it comes to
like things that you,
if you're like a,
if you're a,
you have a blind spot,
the blind spot is you don't respect
women or you have a blind spot.
You don't,
you don't like black people or you don't
like gay people.
If you have a real blind spot,
like a real,
that's going to emanate through all your
thinking.
Totally.
It's gonna fuck up your logic and how
you look at anything that happens in the
world that you tried to turn it into a
bit,
that prejudice thinking like if you,
if you think you have that kind of a
stupid hate and anger or resentment,
whatever it is in your mind,
we not thinking clearly you're going to
miss things.
You're not gonna be as good as you want
to be.
It's going to be at your best.
That's why I do a podcast.
Why didn't they laugh for like,
I literally just,
Ah,
I don't always do it because I'm not
always on the road,
but I'll,
I'll just show bombs and just almost
like,
it's like sports where I'm like,
why didn't that work?
And it motivated me to try shit a lot
because I was like,
okay,
I got an hour,
I gotta want to do another hour.
So let's make it fun.
That like,
I get to be like,
oh,
this one was on me.
I rushed this one,
this tag offended Miami,
you know,
like shit like that.
Like where it's humbling to re listen to
yourself and show up.
Like I did a documentary,
60 minutes and seven days where I wrote
a new hour and a week just to remember
that.
Yeah,
that a few years back,
right when you're out here.
My wife was pregnant so I was like maybe
two years maybe.
And so it would just be like,
watch me just struggle,
you know?
And I maybe got 15 minutes out of it,
but it was just like heavy bag were
amazing though.
You got 15 minutes and that short of a
time,
like how long would it take you to make
15 minutes in a normal time.
I mean if I'm in the wrong mindset like
we discussed that could do that for 3:30
years.
You see guys do that,
you know,
if you're in the mindset of like,
oh this work,
so I'm just going to do that.
But if you're in the growth mindset,
you're like,
because I love doing new shit,
you know?
Well,
isn't it interesting like you coming
from a music background,
like you know you've been playing piano,
like you said,
as long as you can remember,
that requires practice,
right?
It requires 10 hours a day.
Yeah.
You have to be dedicated and sit down a
practice.
That is one of the major things that
comedians lack.
They don't practice.
We don't,
right.
We don't sit down and go over the
material.
We don't listen to the old recordings.
Like when I forced myself into doing
that just four or five times a week,
just forced myself for an hour at a
time.
It's like a giant accomplishment,
you know?
Sometimes it hurts to listen to old sets
like oh my God,
just the mistakes.
And like even when you were like,
okay,
there was a crazy bomb in that one.
It's going to make for a great episode
and then like my instincts are like,
you don't want to relive that man.
That's like that.
That's where I party.
Like dude,
I got,
I got spit on on Christmas.
It didn't make a video about that.
Yeah.
I saw that video and it was like,
you know,
there's a strong instinct of me to put
out my best shit all the time.
But like part of me also wants to be
like this.
This also happens,
you know,
like even like Shit,
I'll be playing like,
like Beethoven,
like my blinkers on with like with like
jokes and it'll just die and I'm like,
why didn't they laugh?
People are in India.
They just decide somewhere along the
line,
I don't want this guy.
Oh,
too tall.
Fermentation is fuck this guy wearing a
suit.
It was some kind of Gig.
Probably anti white power probably
doesn't even have a tattoo on his
forehead.
Where's your fucking swastika on your
street?
I was a kid,
the city once I walked out in a suit and
someone yelled,
faggot before I said one word woe.
Good club literally just goes,
like I said,
one word.
Good work environment.
Yeah.
Imagine any other job.
We show up for work and they just scream
faggot at ya.
And they paid to be there.
It's called systemic oppression.
Just any other job.
That would never be insane.
Just people throw shit at you.
Yeah.
Imagine if you will.
A school teacher did.
I used to be a heckler to renaissance
festival in stock.
Yeah.
That was my high school job.
That's a lyric.
People were throwing tomatoes in my face
all day long and you had mock them,
mock them.
That's what I learned.
I learned to mock what people have pride
in.
Not what is where.
It's like a 400 pound man.
Fatness doesn't matter.
Someone 10 pounds overweight.
It will crush him.
Woo.
Yeah.
Where?
It's a little fucking soft in the middle
there,
Michael.
Yeah.
Your wife's too hot for you?
I'm fucking young.
Mean Tick Tock Tick Tock,
you know,
they freak out because I was getting
paid based on the tomato thrown.
Oh,
dollars a tomato.
It was $5 for three tomatoes and my goal
is always to beat the house.
And Dude,
I used to get drunk on meade and just
let people slap me in the face for $20,
$20 a full power slap.
I would,
I would judge the man but like it would
be like,
because people wouldn't be able to hit
me if I got in their head.
They just like throw it into the ground,
like once you own it.
So mad.
But my,
my friends,
uh,
I was like Kurt Metzger,
you know,
it didn't fall for the shit.
Like I'd be like you.
And it's like now we know you're just
owing on leash.
That's Larry.
That's funny dude.
I gotta wrap this up because it's almost
5:00.
Wow.
Time flew by.
So this is great.
It's four hours and 15 minutes.
About 15 minutes.
It's definitely a highlight of something
like that.
My Week.
Dude.
Thank you very much man.
I really enjoyed it.
It was fun.
We should do it again for sure.
Anytime.
Oh,
tell people how to find you on
instagram.
Twitter,
log jobs.
Huge pianist.com.
And Add Dns to pee in piano player.
Yeah.
I Got Dallas,
Plano in the United Kingdom and Ireland
coming up.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Funny Dude.
Oh,
I'm Benjamin.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Can I say tomorrow?
Black.